the florida senate has passed the
anti-riot
bill ron desantis is expected to sign it
sometime next week
and the villa is considered
controversial because of course the left
and democrats think it stifles free
speech
whereas it actually increases penalties
for a lot of riot related activities
so hey maybe it's a good thing a lot of
people are sick and tired of the far
left black lives matter and antifa going
around smashing things riding non-stop
and they keep getting cut loose but
there are some drawbacks
i mean the things they're doing are
already illegal and if many of these
people aren't being prosecuted then
maybe the problem is the da's aren't
prosecuting the law so we're going to
talk about this but
i also want to get into as this is the
the the week of
the chauvin trials come to an end and
now the trial itself has effectively
come to an end
to the extent that the deliberations
begin next week
and there's an op-ed from fox news
saying that chauvin's lost
the state has proven their case and uh
we're going to have to go and and
we have to go through this because i
think that's absolutely not the case and
i think one of our guests actually
agrees with that
we've got will chamberlain of human
events
you want a quick introduction sure uh
well channel i'm a lawyer
i'm the co-publisher of human events and
run the opinion section um and i'm also
senior counsel at the internet
accountability project in the article
three project
oh does that have to do with uh stopping
censorship exactly it's
article three project was getting
trump's judges confirmed we were big in
the kavanaugh fight and then
internet accountability project is still
ongoing and that's uh
that's yeah that's big tech and
censorship we're working on uh
something in that area to guarantee
access to platforms and create an open
source networking thing
so uh cool stuff we also have jordan
lancaster of the daily caller
hello uh i'm jordan lancaster reporter
at the daily caller
i've covered the riots uh media
pretty much a ride variety of stuff so
happy to be here
awesome we have uh ian crossland what's
up dudes shamanistic dmt trips
call her back at your boy all right all
right up in the house
i do like dmt trips by the way lydia
okay that's here i believe i believe
that and that's iancrosslin.net right
it is yeah yeah yeah you i was thinking
of something last night i came up with a
brilliant
pun about ian crossland you can find him
at ian crossland across the land
no joke i'm a genius you're very welcome
i'm sorry
thank you guys
back to tim hey before we get started go
to tipgus.com and become a member to get
access to exclusive segments for members
only we are building up the site we're
gonna be launching a lot of really cool
things we got some sitcoms we're
potentially gonna be funding
we're gonna be doing a new show on
paranormal weird murder mystery stuff
and we're gonna bring on writers to
produce that content and we're gonna
have general news
commentary culture probably films
probably documentaries
like we're taking this thing all the way
it's gonna be a big digital media empire
with your help that's the direction
we're going so if you like what we do
then become a member at timcast.com but
don't forget to like share subscribe
smash that notification bell
and well smash the like button i guess
smash the notification bell as well
but uh if you're listening on itunes
spotify or google or whatever podcast
platform
leave us a good review give us five
stars tell all your friends how awesome
we are because that really does help
let's jump into this first story and uh
this is this is it's kind of a crazy
story i suppose it's either really
really good
unless i guess you're a democrat then
you're probably really angry about if
you're a black lives matter protester
the florida senate has passed the
controversial anti-riot bill
pushed in the wake of black lives matter
protests governor ron desantis
championed the legislation
and is expected to sign it as early as
next week one of the things it does
that democrats are really mad about is
that if you are in your
car and a group of protesters are in the
street
and you're trying to escape them you are
immune from civil liability if you drive
through them so it's you know you want
to make sure you get all that context in
there
but they're freaking out because they're
trying to make it seem like they're
granting immunity to people literally
slamming the gas and like crashing into
people that's not the case
but there are a bunch of other
provisions that make certain things a
felony
now i'll say this because i'll need your
help on this one will
i tried looking up what the bill does
specifically like a breakdown
unfortunately if you go to right wing
sites they tell you very specific things
like this becomes a felony
certain left wing sites say very biased
things and
reading through it it's like i don't
know it's not that many pages but it's
very
poorly written so can you give us the
gist of what this anti-riot law does
sure well i actually found like their
summary you know i went to the florida
legislature and and
got an idea of what they're doing um i
think the biggest thing
it does i mean it's it's really first
off there's a lot of enhanced penalties
so if you're
you know committing one of these crimes
like inciting a riot participating in
riot
uh it's gonna there's like a mandatory
minimum for assaulting a police officer
now of six months for example
um it also means that if you're
participating in riot and you get
arrested you can't
get bailed out before you appear in
court so it's like the sort of
in and out i'd like i think that's a
great one um
it allows it has a it has this defunding
anti-defunding the police provision
which essentially makes the state before
city wants to defund its beliefs it
needs permission from
from the state government uh it looks
like
it this is an interesting one and i
think this is the one that has to do
with the whole uh
the defense about like if you run
someone over it says it creates an
affirmative defense in a civil
action arising from a riot if the
plaintiff's injury or damage was
sustained as a result of participating
in a riot so that
that's sort of interesting that sort of
shuts off any sort of lawsuits by
rioters like if you're in a riot and
you get assaulted or something so it's
actually beyond so so the democrats are
the ones framing it as though you could
run
your car through them right but actually
it's much broader than that
well it's civil liability too right like
say you say i think that's a good
example right you're participating in a
riot
um and i don't actually know the extent
of this affirmative defense i'd actually
need to read it like
you know how far that goes but the basic
concept if somebody is escaping you
don't have the right to sue them
because you were participating in a riot
and they were trying to get out of it
and they why do we need a law for that
if you're committing a felony
and i'm trying to escape why am i liable
for this i mean apparently
you know i think it's good to just make
it really clear actually
you know because people one of the
things i i have a very strong view about
people guess stopping traffic
uh i consider i mean that's fa that
should be false imprisonment it should
be treated as a very serious crime
i really disagree with you you know i
think no like i think protests are
stopping traffic it's like straight to
jail
everybody and throw the book at those
people because that's it's it's
incredibly selfish there are people
who are trying to just get to work go to
their jobs it's incredibly scary
right you're just like you're you're at
the mercy of this mob um
and it's just it's the most selfish way
to protest possible
it's completely indifferent to like the
amount of time and energy you're taking
away from everybody who's blocked
you're just you're deciding you're more
important than they are that becomes a
felony right
blocking traffic i think so i think the
bill makes like a third degree felony i
think they've been much more aggressive
about it and i
i really disagree with that when i think
that you know
if it was just a bunch of say like i
don't know code pink
and they're holding hands in the middle
of dc singing songs and the cops have to
walk up and one by one arrest them and
remove them and it takes
20 or 30 minutes non-violence of
disobedience is a good thing we don't
want people to be getting violent
um i mean i'm okay with that except do
it on a sidewalk like get out of the
road
but that's the point the point is to
create some kind of circumstance where
it generates attention
and my point is that i think that's not
something we should incentivize and
instead that we should deter
i think a fair point is that see people
standing on the road create a very
serious risk standing in a road and you
probably shouldn't stand in a road
period
right my thing is more just like we want
we need to make sure there's a space
maintained where people can be
to a certain degree disruptive
peacefully and non-violently
and it's already illegal so typically
what happens is when people are holding
hands in the street
they immediately get arrested sometimes
takes longer if they use like chains to
like link their hands together or those
like metal tubes
but they when a peaceful protester
stands in the street the cop walks up
coughs them and walks them away they
clear the traffic relatively quickly
and the protesters get their point
across they do get charged it's usually
a misdemeanor slap on the wrist
and then they're not going around
smashing windows and beating people in
the streets like they're doing now
i mean i think like well there's already
laws that are you know don't
pun we aren't seriously punishing people
on the road and they still
you know i don't think that's a way to
divert them from breaking windows
i think it's like you know a felony is
kind of intense though for that man
right but well then there's don't do it
like just don't do it it's the law
don't do it you know i mean i think you
have to think about the worst case
scenario right like what if an ambulance
is trying to get through
this traffic and they can't or like
there was a video that went viral
um a while ago of some guy he got out of
his car
and a mob was blocking him from getting
in the road and this is a doctor
and he was like he like worked in the er
or something he's like i need to get to
work
you got patience the challenge i suppose
is the difference between an unruly mob
in the street
and like a bunch of hippies holding
hands singing and then the cops come and
clear them out
yeah i think those are different things
but in this scenario it was
a giant mob of people in an intersection
right that's right
and what's stopping the hippies from
getting a permit like if you want to if
you want to march on the street
get a permit there's ways to do that i
don't know man first amendment says
piece of peaceably assembled well do you
guys remember the la riots more recently
not the actual l.a riots
in the 60s but there were la rios yeah
yeah yeah i'm a little bit off like 30
years
they blocked a highway in la and there
was an ambulance that was stuck in the
traffic and a little girl
died because of it like that's for me
the biggest argument against
like blocking traffic and i kind of
agree with them they should be charged
with murder yeah absolutely
right like that's a serious issue well i
think we should just you know at the
outset just deter this behavior entirely
like i mean if people actually start
going to jail for serious time for doing
this it will stop
people will find other ways to make
their point heard and there's plenty of
ways in this world to get your point
across
yeah my main thing is like if it's
already illegal why are we making more
laws for it
because people are still doing it so the
punishments aren't severe enough
apparently
i'm not sure that they care i mean i
will say a point i've made in the past
few days is that the cost
for riding is too low and these people
know this
even though it is a felony to go and do
you know burn a building to the ground
they know they're gonna get cut loose
that let you see that lady in in
uh portland who burned down the or sat
fire to the police union building
they released her without bail yeah they
released her yeah it's just
right rioting is not drug addiction
where people can't stop
right right like and that it's not and
therefore it's like overly punitive into
chronic no
you don't have to riot you have no
addiction to rioting you're just doing
it because you want to
so stop it we just need to change the
law so that people go right to jail
this uh this woman apparently she got
informed on because
some one of these anti-guys in portland
is apparently a snitch she was arrested
apparently last year i guess
and she was released and all the charges
were dropped
if this woman was if the charges were
not dropped
and she got a year in jail or a year
plus in prison
she would not have been there to set
fire to this police association building
they cut her loose dropped the charges
and they knew
she was a violent terroristic extremist
then she goes and does it again
and what happens she gets f i think it's
five felony charges
wow and they release her with with
without without bail on our own
recognizance i think that's called right
right and i mean the beauty of doing
this in you know conservative states
there's a lot of blue cities and there's
still blue cities in in florida
but all of a sudden they've got you know
the state attorney general can come in
and
tell them to knock it off right right
now you're essentially oregon is totally
dependent
on federal law enforcement um and the
fbi run by
a republican pr administration at some
point in the future
otherwise you're just you're just sol
yeah
i like the uh you can't get released
until your first court hearing
you're caught in a riot you know there
are challenges about this
uh typically my thing is blackstone's
formulation the presumption of innocence
it's really difficult to you you might
be walking through the wrong place at
the right wrong time and they'll charge
you with being in a riot
and you know what then right well i mean
i think the the right answer is to
really reduce the number of riots
like that let's let's start there if we
just reduce the number of riots then
that also reduces the number of people
who are randomly walking through makes
police's job a lot easier
means they can focus on combating crime
in their cities
and not have to send these huge forces
of people just to you know
deal with unruly riders so so you know
when i asked about
why make new laws if it's already
illegal you said something to the effect
of the punishment must not have been
severe enough
right like if it's still happening
despite being illegal all the time
we are not deterring it sufficiently
because the district attorneys aren't
prosecuting it
that might be true but this is a
solution to that as well right if you
create
new state laws with severe punishments
and
you know essentially you create an
environment also where the state
attorney general is going to want to
enforce those laws if local district
attorneys are not
and that authority i'm pretty sure is
always there so long as at the state
level
i guess my my bigger concern then is one
of the statements made by democrats is
that this is going to be
disproportionately used
it's going to be biased it's going to be
used against them
they're they're half right i think if
you look at the evidence
they've consistently the the black lives
matter the antivirus have consistently
gotten away with
serious violent extremism i mean how
many people died in the riots
or peripheral to the riots of last year
it was like 30 something something yeah
yeah there were there were 19 i think
deaths directly related and then
peripheral deaths like people and
ambulances that couldn't get to the
hospital and stuff like that
these people have gotten away with i
mean kamala harris solicited donations
to get these people out of jail joe
biden and staff donated to these funds
to get these people out of jail
and then people voted for them then you
look at the the people at the capitol
there's one lady apparently the door was
open and she had no idea what was going
on until she walked in
you know dumbfounded and bewildered like
everybody else and now she's in solitary
confinement facing like 40 years in
prison yeah
i mean that's the cur that's the status
quo the left gets off a lot easier and
that's not all about like selective
prosecution that's also about
you know 50 to 60 years of leftist
organizing infrastructure and protest
infrastructure still existing
i mean the national lawyers guild
they're still around and in the 70s
they were hiding terrorists right
weather underground terrorists and we
i mean we it's amazing when you actually
read about what the 70s weather
underground did they were bombing all
over the place
um and they they just got
six months they got like probation when
they finally they were they were
fugitives for ten years and they finally
turned themselves in and got probation
who was weather underground i've heard
of them a lot bill ayers
bill ayers so uh weather underground
came out of students for democrats
students for a democratic society a
radical left-wing student group
um after in the i think in the
very early 70s um they made the decision
to that you know we actually are we need
the revolution is coming
and so uh after like they went to a big
protest in
chicago and a bunch of them got indicted
on various like rioting assault charges
a bunch of them instead of returning to
face those charges they went what
underground
um which at the time just meant well
okay i'm not going to show for my court
date i'm not going to be a fugitive and
i'm going to go get
you know new identity documents and and
just live under the radar
and not be you know not be employed it
was much easier to do then because
it was just easy to fake make get a fake
id no internet
right so um that was you know and so
there was a big there's a group
it ended up being about like 150
left-wing people and they started out
they i mean apparently there was a plan
to actually go after and
set off bombs in an army base while
people were there that failed and
ultimately a bunch of them
killed themselves in a bomb accident in
their own town house wow uh
and then after that they decided we're
only going to bomb things symbolically
but they were
you know there was just there was a
bombing campaign all over the place
where they would just set off bombs and
you know energy stations and random
places to make a political point
so we have decades of that
infrastructure and the remnants of that
still exist today
yeah so when it comes to this new law
how long until a democrat wins florida
assuming they do
maybe maybe it swings back hardly the
direction in the next few years maybe
not maybe i mean it was it was fairly
close this time around democrat takes
over and then all of a sudden the
republicans find themselves with
you know a boot on their face well i
mean it's possible but you know
i think republicans republicans
generally don't riot and you know one of
the things they said about january 6 is
the reason they
were even able to get into the capital
is because republicans generally don't
do that
you know they weren't prepared they
weren't the capital police weren't
prepared for it at all they weren't
really understaffed what if a right-wing
group decides to march around and they
got flags and they find themselves
marching in the street and also they're
all committing felonies and they'll get
locked up
i mean i'll don't do that the law says
don't do it
but if if you're if you're a regular
person and you're coming out waving your
flag you're on a street corner and
everyone's cheering
and then you start marching and then
you're in the street not realizing
what's going on you don't know the law
and then all of a sudden they're like
thank you so much for this law
that that 40 you know that that's 50
year old grandmother is now a felon
and they lock her up and they put her in
solitary i mean they've
one they've already done that in federal
law right right that's what i'm saying
so it's like
i expect more it's quite possible that
democrats will use this stuff against us
but
i mean i think the net trade-off given
how few sort of
riots there are from the right like
january 6 was such a bizarre aberration
i mean i remember just being surprised
it's like our side never does this this
is
left uh did this all summer and all all
the time the right never does
i literally published a video at 1 pm
that day where i was like nothing's
happening
trump's speaking everyone's waving
little flags this is boring
yeah and then 10 minutes later they
pushed past the barricade and then 40
minutes later
you know oh it's so stupid yeah so
stupid so anyway i'm just i'm not
pro-riding like i just don't care don't
riot i'm concerned how they redefine
riot
in the coming years because if they make
a law about what you can and can't do
when you're rioting then all of a sudden
they're going to make a law about what
the word right yeah
that's in it it changes it to three or
more people engaging in tumultuous
activity so if i go on the corner and
start playing music and i have four
people around me yelling
and they're excited they could say i'm
rioting maybe but then there's there's
always this first amendment constraint
in the background right yeah
so like i mean i think and and i'm
confident in the ability of federal
courts
to enforce the first amendment and
strike down laws
even just as applied right if they try
to use one of these riot laws to
something that is clearly first
amendment protected activity is
i'm confident a court strike it down
what are they going to do about
journalists who are there covering it
one
one there's the problem of people there
who are actual journalists who have
you know their cameras and stuff and
then
there's people who fake it you know
there have been a lot of people at these
riots who have fake press credentials
so are they gonna arrest everybody
including
people who are there as reporters or are
they going to let reporters go and then
have people fake it
they'll arrest them they you know i mean
two of our
two of our reporters got arrested yeah
yeah
i remember i'll tell you this the the
simple thing is
if you're a journalist and you're
working the protest beat be nice to the
cops
like be calm very calm and have your
press credentials readily available
ask for a supervisor very calmly and
politely if it doesn't happen keep your
mouth shut
so i've been in so many of these
circumstances and i remember in dc on
trump's inauguration several journalists
got pulled out of the mass arrest
i was one of them why had my card i
asked for a supervisor
the guy came over and said you're under
arrest i was like just wanna let you
know i'm pressed and he goes nah doesn't
matter i was like
you got it just let you know he came
back later and he looked at some
journalists and he was like you come
with me you come with me and i was like
yo yo no
come with me he pulled us out show me
your card he said all right you guys are
good to go
you know sorry about that some other
journalists were in the crowd screaming
at the top of their lungs you
[ __ ] are you kidding me
they went to jail and then they had all
of the activists cheer them on they came
out
and these people are hardcore activists
that's why they're screaming at cops and
they're angry
so as part of the job you're not
supposed to get arrested but you get
arrested
a real a real professional journalist in
my opinion gets arrested and they
grumble about it
and they keep their mouth shut and they
let their boss know the moment it's
happening if they can
they say you know they'll yell to
someone tell you know channel five i'm
being arrested and then they'll
peacefully put their hands behind the
back and then go through the motions and
then when the
you know the station will call them the
police usually say okay you're free to
go
but when you scream in their faces and
start a fight and you get locked up
if you're screaming at the cops and
starting a fight with them you're
probably not a real
journalist or a real reporter yep i
think it's fair to say
we defend the act of journalism someone
becomes a journalist the moment they're
engaging in journalism but if you
combine at any point the active
journalism with the act of rioting or
can or or screaming at cops
now you're an active participant you may
be in active journalism
but you're also i'll put this way the
first amendment says peaceably assemble
meaning if you violently assemble or
illegally assemble then
you're not peaceably assembling illegal
is where it gets interesting and
there are probably case law challenges
but the general idea is
if you're not breaking the law or
putting people at risk
you're probably fine the same thing is
true for if you're engaging in an act of
the press
if you start acting violently you know
the press is implied that you're being
peaceful
if you're now throwing bricks at people
and filming it that's not journalism you
know
i think it's fair to say it's
i think 13 states that have the same
bill so if it went through then would a
journalist who
steps onto the street be committing a
felony
doubtful well they could charge it but i
don't think it would fly
they could charge it because they'll say
you know let's say you're there
and you're filming and you're in a group
of three or more engaging in tumultuous
activity
they'll say ah you're in the street
felony you're under arrest then you'll
go
you'll probably have to go before a
judge you'll tell the judge i'm a
reporter here's where i work the judge
will be like okay you're free to go
if you can't prove you work somewhere
he'll probably say i don't believe you
you know your court date is this it's
tough
it's not easy the first amendment is
interesting it defends the press but now
everybody's the press
so i guess the the the the problem now
is like
the question you ask if you're a
journalist and you enter the street and
you're obstructing it now
got a problem i mean i don't know like
i'm looking at the statute it changes
the definition to someone who
participates in a violent public
disturbance involving an assembly of
three or more persons
acting with a common intent to assist
each other in a violent and disorderly
context so yeah
violence is part of writing that
wouldn't include journalists right now
journalists are free then
yeah unless you're filming yourself
throwing bricks at people and
journalists
if you're filming and throwing a water
bottle then the more important part is
you're throwing a water bottle right
exactly well let's let's jump over to
the next story because
um the next one is whether or not we're
going to see massive riots across the
country
right yes yes or no answer will will we
see substantially worse rights this
this year oh man uh
substantially worse no i won't say
substantially worse because they were
real bad last year
don't think it'll be worse this time no
i think the police will be better
prepared seems like they've been better
prepared in uh brooklyn center do you
think there will be riots
yes all right we got this story from fox
news which i found
i'm sorry i laughed when i said it when
i saw it greg jarrett says
derek chauvin prosecutors meet the
burden of proof
in trial what and he opens by saying
defending the
indefensible can be futile and fatuous
endeavor
and then he talks a lot about stuff blah
blah blah at the end he says
it is never easy to reach a decision
unanimously when presented with
conflicting testimony as noted herein
jurors tend to resort to common sense
and wisdom grounded in their own life
experiences
in this case the great weight of the
evidence favors the prosecution
it has sustained the burden of proof but
a reasonable doubt
that what derek chovin did was not only
wrong but criminal
i can't believe that's true uh based on
everything i've seen so far
and i'm curious mr lawyer if you agree
with greg jarrett that the prosecution's
prosecution has met the burden of proof
proving that uh derrick chauvin was uh
not only wrong but criminal i i don't
think they've proved causation beyond
reasonable doubt
um i don't think i thought dr fowler's
testimony i thought was
very reasonable um there's just a lot of
potential
alternate causality here i mean the guy
had a 90 blocked heart artery he was ta
he had 11 man
nanograms per milliliter of fentanyl in
the system along with methamphetamine
and i think it was what 5.6 of north
fentanyl meaning metabolization yeah
metabolized fentanyl i mean
you had the testimony about him sleeping
in the in the car it had to be roused
um he decided to fight with the officers
and have this huge adrenaline spike
that could have been a heart attack and
well so so here's here's my issue right
so let's go through the charges this guy
is saying they met the burden of proof i
don't see that we've got murder two
murder three we've got a manslaughter on
second degree and
uh assault in the third degree which is
they're go
the murder two they're going for is the
felony murder rule correct so that means
they're they're they're arguing that
chauvin did not want to kill george
floyd yeah there's no there's no
none of the charges require intent to
kill that's that's the key thing to
understand right they're going for
unintentional murder two
depraved heart murder three which is
also unintentional and then involuntary
manslaughter
so that's all none of that requires
intent to kill so that's why they didn't
spend any time proving it
there was a point in the trial that i
wrote several times where the defense
cross-examined
the state's use of force expert from la
and based on the continuum chart it's at
the continuum where shows like
passive resistance which is you know
going limp or
you know not standing up active
resistance which is fighting
and then active aggression where you're
like shooting at somebody in the
category
this guy said in this continuum the
defense
expert witness i'm sorry sorry the
prosecution's expert witness said
george floyd was actively resisting
right next to it it says
it said like electro whatever you know
force compliance or whatever which is a
taser and
nelson the defense attorney said so
chauvin could have used a taser
immediately upon encountering george
floyd
actively resisting the other officers
and the prosecution's witness said
yes and he goes and then chauvin chose a
lesser force option
of restraint instead and the expert
witness for the prosecution said yes
that to me right away threw everything
out the window
it seems like based on that argument
alone chauvin was trying
not to hurt the man right to minimize
right you could see i mean
that could in and of itself be
reasonable doubt i think this the
defense is going to have
problems because the defense use of
force expert was a clown
yeah a complete clown i mean the attempt
to say that it wasn't a use of force to
hold the guy on the ground because
well it's a straight position so there's
not even an inquiry as to whether or not
the force was excessive i mean i thought
that was in
it was indefensible it was revealed on
cross to be indefensible you basically
like retracted his
entire opinion uh within five minutes of
cross-examination so that was really bad
and i think
it's a it was a huge miss opportunity
for the defense because i think you're
right because you know
there were the defense use of force
experts plural
had conflicting testimony i mean you had
the lapd guy
saying that holding somebody in the
prone position under the circumstances
was justified use of force
and then you had the academic saying it
wasn't right uh and
all you need is a guy to get up there
and say which is it
you know which is it and but just you
have your own defense expert who says
look under the totality of these
circumstances this was a justified use
of force
rather than trying to say it wasn't a
use of force at all like you just say
like given the resistance and given the
fact that they thought he was going
through anxiety delirium it was
reasonable for them to hold him on the
ground
uh and try and and just restrain him and
prevent it from moving and that's what
they were doing
the crazy thing to me is that they're
trying to claim that chauvin murdered
floyd
that he was the he was the cause of
death but they can't even tell us
definitively what the cause of death was
right i mean they they they say that
it's a hundred percent
low you know positional asphyxia they
changed their position
initially it was that it was pressure to
the neck cutting off
oxygen to the brain and then apparently
because of one of their own experts
testifying
about how the knee had moved they
switched it up to saying it was you know
pressure
resulting in low respiratory function
yeah i mean the weakest part of so tobin
says it was both
the knee on the back and the holding him
in the prone position and then also the
knee on the side of the neck at times
um which to me honestly doesn't make
that much sense because i mean i don't
know if you've like done this but like
this isn't near your airway
right like the idea that knee on the
back of the neck would close your airway
just doesn't make sense is that what he
said close your airway
right like it would it would lead to
your breathing expert i guess right he
was a breathing expert but
and the the defense expert said there's
there's no literature on this
like and to me that was the moment of
like yeah
i mean you're saying he choked via that
and then the positional asphyxia thing
um it's the fowler was able to suggest
pretty strongly that
the guy who like came up with the idea
and wrote about it said it really only
applies to people who are obese because
you're pressing their gut up into their
lungs it doesn't apply to people like
floyd who was
quite you know 6 6 230 but very lean how
do you how do you con
what is the argument the closing
argument from the prosecution going to
be could you even predict it i mean the
closing argument is going to be
use unjustified use of force means it's
assault so that's
that's murder too uh the knee on the
neck is so egregious and appalling that
that means it's murder three two
um and then he died of positional
asphyxia dr tobin said he did listen to
him
and the other guy's not credible he was
paid something
i mean they had one of their defense
experts i think a couple of their
experts were paid as well but
sure yeah and i don't i don't think
being paid in the circumstances is
i mean i don't think it makes you more
or less credible i mean the fact that
you're volunteering and wanting to try
and put a guy in jail is weird
i agree yeah having this guy be like i
want to fly out here and then come and
speak so that i can you know make my
i mean the prosecution team they had the
most they had neil cat y'all
do you know i don't know if you guys
know neil cat y'all he was my former
criminal law professor he was former
acting solicitor general of the united
states
he was serving on the prosecution he was
like they brought him in for motions
practice right to argue
to argue some of the legal points he
would zoom in and like argue them and so
you've got eric nelson the random
criminal defense attorney
are you against neil catyal who argues
more supreme court cases every year than
any
other private wow like just why
oh and the prosecution team is also
mostly private attorneys uh what
so blackwell um the the the bald black
guy
and then and then schleicher who handled
who handled a lot of the other cross
examination
both of them are like private litigators
that that keith ellison brought in to
handle the case
there's only like one state prosecutor
the the woman the
woman with brown hair she was the only
prosecutor who's actually a prosecutor
in her day job
they overcharged chauvin yeah they
should have gone with what manslaughter
i mean i think man two is the correct
charge here but you don't even think
he'll get that i don't think he'll get
that because i think
i think at the end of the day there's
going to be a juror who says to himself
i don't know how he died yup that's
reasonable doubt but
even if even if the jar is like i think
he most
likely died because of the knee on the
neck that's still
doubt right right he could still he
still gets off in that case
like you you know and that's going to
come up that the closing's going to
focus on that i guarantee you
the the defense attorney is a smart guy
i guarantee you that defense attorney
knows he's in a lot
bit you know i guess deeper water on use
of force than he is on causation
and he's going to drill down and be like
unless you are a hundred percent certain
that chauvin died of positional asphyxia
not guilty
yeah right floyd
i think didn't cahill mention in
september it looked like floyd swallowed
pills
there was a tweet i pulled up from it
from like a local journalist
yeah i mean there was there was there
were pills in the back of the squad car
with his saliva on them
the speed ball a half-chewed speed ball
found in the squad car yeah
so i i i pulled this up there was a
tweet from back in september when they
were you know setting up the trial
setting up the
the case where the judge said that he it
looked like in the photos
floyd had swallowed pills do you think
the defense is going to bring up to the
jury
george floyd was seen on camera
ingesting what appeared to be drugs
he was with a man that was testified by
his own girlfriend to be their drug
dealer
they found drugs in the vehicle and he
had the drugs in his system which as
you've heard already
fentanyl depresses your respiratory
system and methamphetamine causes heart
arrhythmia
we can't be sure how george floyd died
yeah
i mean there's there's a very powerful
closing and it's it's a lot harder
to rule it out i mean they basically
have to rely on these
pieces of dr tobin testimony that said
well if you had a heart attack you would
have seen this and this and this
who gets the last word though
prosecution does right yeah but i mean
the prosecution already had its
i think yeah the prosecution gets the
last word in in opening or uh
yeah that's powerful it is but it's
still beyond a reasonable doubt and i
think i think at the end of the day the
defense has it
um i've seen you know i think about the
robert durst case where the guy
literally
uh uh what's the word for uh not
decapitated but uh
dismembered dismembered his neighbor uh
the dismembered body was you know pieces
of the dismembered body were found in
the
in the lake or in the in the river the
axe used to do the dismembering was
found in
in durst's car um
what what was this this was uh this is a
great hbo show called the jinx which you
have to watch
oh you haven't seen it yeah yeah the
jinx the jinx it's incredible
um and uh he claimed self-defense
you know um said said that the guy was
his friend
and uh you know you you know when do you
dismember someone in self-defense
so how did he get acquitted that's
that's he gotta he managed to give
persuade reasonable doubt that he that
the
thing that led to his he's like i didn't
murder him i did dismember him
i think it was it wasn't at the new york
post that the headline was
durst who cut up body claims
self-defense
that was the new york times that said
that wow
yeah it was that was a headline well
hold on there's something we got to
consider though
if tonight we see rioting and i think
one of these jurors lives in brooklyn
center
and the rest of the jurors still have to
commute through riots
to get to court do you think they're
going to show up on monday sweating
bullets knowing that if they say not
guilty that it's going to be a brick
through their window and their house on
fire
maybe i mean i could see somebody
hanging the jury because of that they're
just like not willing to go with a not
guilty verdict so i say i think
you know i think hung jury is a real
possibility here and that means they
redo the trial again later right right
it would just be a mistrial
wow um what's the difference between
murder three and
manslaughter uh murder three is what's
called depraved heart
uh murder so like that's supposed to be
really really
you know involuntary manslaughter is is
you know killing someone without intent
right generally it's that's the usual
crime like for example uh
the dante wright case where the woman
mistake mistook her taser for
a mistake her gun for a taser and shot
the guy that's an involuntary means on
her charge
so the so the one cop says she i don't
think she's actually made her statement
yet
right right fair enough but like that's
what they charge that's the first thing
they charged um but depraved
murder is is things that are like really
beyond the pale that indicate a depraved
heart
so you know juggling chainsaws juggling
chainsaws
and then you throw someone at somebody
or something the i think i read that the
classic case in black letter law is
uh two people are playing a modified
russian roulette where they're trying
shooting
you know there's one bullet and a
revolver and they're shooting each other
and finally one of them died
and they're like okay that's not
involuntary manslaughter even if you
didn't have intent to kill right
that's so beyond the pale weird there
but it's not it's not supposed to be
that common third degree murder is not
supposed to be that common
um so they're claiming that
that what that he he was he like in his
mind he was like
i don't want to kill him but man i hope
he dies like that kind of something or
like you just i don't care that i'm
putting my knee on his neck and
suffocating you know and suffocating him
even if i'm not trying to kill him i
don't care that i'm inflicting this much
pain
weird distinction and this doesn't even
matter yeah i mean it's
it's just it's there so that sometimes
things that are really beyond the pale
can get more years
the prosecution's own witness i think
more than one testified that the the
position chauvin was in was a ground
control technique that they actually
train
the brazilian jiu jitsu guy said yes
that's a ground control technique so
it's like
i'm sorry man look nobody wants
well i should say most people don't want
anyone dying right there's a faction of
murderers i suppose they exist and
depraved individuals
that's why we have murder charges but i
mean nobody wanted to see anybody die in
the dante right case in the in the adam
toledo case and george floyd
but the cop shows up deshoven was told
it was a priority one right
that means sirens rush in guy's actively
resisting
he shows up and he sees floyd resisting
and he chooses not to tase him
i'm gonna restrain him anyway i'm gonna
use a ground control technique
everyone's screaming in his face one
guy's an mma fighter
and he's being held back by someone else
that was one of the the most amazing
things to me about the case this guy was
an mma fighter testified he put him in a
blood choke
and then when nelson shows the videos
like there's the mma fighter
in front of chauvin who's what five nine
one forty pounds and someone was holding
this guy back
stance the reason that chauvin felt he
was in a very serious
threatening he was a little distracted
like i would be distracted in the
circumstances how do they not
have reasonable doubt it's it's like i'm
sorry but at this point
i have like it's not it's not reasonable
doubt it's like
what's overt uh uh
disbelief you know what i mean like
right like you think you mean you just
think he's innocent
yeah i know right like that's that's
simple i love how the left is their
attitude is but we saw it on video
yeah it's like all the context the
training
policing none of it matters and i can't
stand how the left is covering this like
they are not preparing
their audience at all for an acquittal
like they're just they're saying that
this is trial is going swimmingly for
the prosecution
and it's like there was a day that went
really well for the prosecution when
they cross examined
yeah the use of force expert but every
every other day i would say
the prosecution has not been that great
um you know they
they had like tons and tons of witnesses
and
nelson was able to get out a lot on
cross i so
so i'm not a lawyer i don't typically
follow criminal trials
and i i thought when
the the prosecution's use of for use of
force experts were testifying
i thought it was a defense witness yeah
i was like wow this is great the defense
is really laying it out and then i was
like wait that's the prosecution's
witness
yikes he brought in a guy to claim that
chauvin was doing what he was supposed
to do
and could have done worse wow yeah i was
like
are they trying to lose or i can't
remember who it was that
we were talking to this head there's
just no case i mean it one on the one
hand it's really hard because there's a
lot of what chauvin is doing
i mean and there's this mismatch too
right like the thing that really seems
like excessive force is in particular
the knee on the neck or in the neck area
and also like holding on to him well
after he's lost his pulse that seems
like excessive force
but so much of everything that led up to
that was was policy
like i think they conceded you know
holding somebody in the prone position
for excited delirium i thought that i'm
pretty sure that was minneapolis policy
right but but also they're like yeah but
why nine minutes because the mma guy
was screaming in his face and being held
back and chauvin was very distracted and
didn't know what was going on
because they were they thought ems was
coming and be right there and they were
just trying to like hold on to them
did you see the prosecution's uh uh
expert use of force witness
who said when he was asked by on cross
have you ever
held someone in a in a restraint until
ems arrived
yes i did yeah it's like
yeah wow that's i mean it's just it's
just true so
yeah i own witnesses over and over and
over again that was crazy to me
yeah and then i i was reading the crazy
thing about it is i'm watching the trial
and like i said the first the first time
i i tuned i i tuned into the to the
cross-examination i thought it was the
defense's own witness and i was like oh
wow we're in the defense
wait a minute the defense hasn't started
their case yet
wow and then i start watching the
mainstream media and what do they do
they show only the highlight reel of one
fighter landing punches
they omit the defense the craziest thing
about that
i think it was slate.com right lefty
publication
where they say is the defense
floundering
and then they're there i see these
articles where they're like the defense
is helpless and i'm like
when your commentary is derivative of
biased news sources and you don't double
check
you write opinions that are based in
just
yeah nobody was watching cross i
remember we were watching i think cnn
uh a couple you know a couple days ago
during um
the defense witnesses and and finally
their analysts were talking about
cross-examination and how
like they were able to ask questions and
things like that and i'm like i realized
you guys haven't even talked about
cross-examination yet yeah you got it's
just
you've only broadcast highlights of
direct yep and you have noah and that
gives you no clue about what's actually
happening
in the case these people have invested
everything in the resistance
in donald trump that's why there are
still these youtubers and there are
still these news outlets that are
writing about donald trump today
it's amazing they talk about january 6
almost every single night i watch cnn
msnbc every night they talk about it
literally i don't know we'll watch them
with me would you say almost every
single night
almost every night i mean rachel maddow
did like 40 minutes on russia
no what 40 minutes talked about russia
trump russia and then she talked about
i think it was dante wright she talked
about for a little bit
or it was yeah there's like there's like
20 minutes of the riots to
russia so these these people have an
audience
of cultists that they've whipped into a
cult
over the past several years and they
know if they give them real information
that offends them their minds will
explode
so they're like okay let's see we have
this trial and the prosecution
expert witness says chovin should not
have done that that's great we'll put
that
uh for for 10 p.m or for 10 a.m then we
have the defense they said
actually he should not have done it but
it was part of his training let's throw
that in the garbage and then
let's this next one says chauvin was
using it because of force we'll put that
right there and then
but that's my opinion and not the facts
because he was trained to do that and
other officers do it as well let's throw
that one in the garbage
right just the highlights this is a
major part of what's stirring up riots
you have
all of these viewers watching what they
think is the facts of the trial they
turn on
cnn msnbc every single night and then
what if he gets off well what they've
been watching is showing them
to them obviously he should have been
convicted
imagine what you know once he gets off
it's like
they have more of a reason to go out and
riot imagine watching a boxing match
where they only show you you know
fighter and in the blue shorts
punching the fighter on the red shorts
over and over again you're like oh this
is brutal it's
over man this is oh geez and then all of
a sudden
they they go to call it and they raise
the arm of the guy in the red shorts
you're like but he didn't land a single
punch they'll even be like why does that
other guy's face look so busted up yeah
it doesn't matter if you want it right
yeah and then they
see it and it'll be cognitive they won't
even question why it looks like
literally that's how the human mind
is built or actually maybe a better way
to put it is like it's a world series
match it's you know baseball
and it's the uh i don't know i don't
know any teams give me a team we got the
white sox
indians do they play against the indy
the socks they play against the whites
no no they play
they wouldn't it would not in the world
series the world series is going to be
national american league so let's say
cubs
so the cubs socks yeah what i guess they
both make it chicago
so there's gonna be a right no matter
what happens i mean it is chicago and uh
basically people are watching
and then they only see the home run
scored by the sox
and they're like wow it's it's it's they
got eight runs in
they must have won and then when it
turns out the cubs had nine they just
don't believe like you're lying
we watched the game we didn't see any of
that and they go around and destroy
everything riot smashing things and just
anger
i mean they're doing it again so the
dante wright thing we were watching on
cnn and msnbc
they always play the clip and you know
what they omit the part where he's being
placed under arrest
and and then evades and gets back into
his car they cut they cut to begin the
thing
right after that happens and while he's
already back in the car in
i think it was it was either 2015 or 16
there was a trump rally
in janesville wisconsin there was an
old man arguing with a young woman she
started screaming he touched my breast
he touched my breast he put his hand up
so i didn't even touch you
then she punches him in the face and
someone pepper sprays her
mike.com added the most
insane edit i've ever seen because it
was within
like one second where he puts his hands
up then she punches them and gets pepper
sprayed
so they added like a flare a white flash
and all it did was cover up her punching
the old man
so all you see her doing is going he
touched my breast he puts his hands up
and then if the screen flashes and she's
going ah getting pepper sprayed
they literally cut out her punching a
guy in the face she was pepper sprayed
in self-defense of others yeah amazing
what goes through your mind when you're
like i'm gonna
edit this video and make this woman not
punch him
why because they're like i'm gonna make
so much money
for this click that's true yep
yeah i don't know it's so dangerous
that's that's public perception that's
the media landscape i'll tell you what
this results in let's jump to this next
story because this is where this is what
we can
we can expect right now so we so we have
the santa riot law come up we got this
the chauvin trial and we think there's
going to be riots
check out this story from scriber news
scriber correspondent attacked while
covering protest
this is kaelin d almeida we know him
yes a night covering black lives matter
los angeles protests had peaceful
moments but parts turned to mayhem in
the evening hours scuffles
broke out as a scriber field
correspondent was attacked
scriber field reporter kailyn de almeida
was attacked at approximately 10 30 p.m
on highland avenue between hawthorne and
selma in hollywood
and this this video is particularly
brutal i i can't play for you the video
but
this is a guy who's just doing
journalism
and they chase him down they stalk him
they follow him they repeatedly like
shove him hit him knock him to the
ground it's particularly bad i i
my understanding and i could be wrong i
believe he got knocked unconscious and
like left
on the ground particularly brutal attack
so we have these roving bands
of i guess terrorists
no they're not vigilantes beating
themselves they see themselves criminals
should be in jail they view themselves
as like righteous
righteous superheroes who should be in
jail
yeah i don't even know if they see
themselves as a resistance honestly i
don't even know if they see themselves
you know what i mean no but but but but
i do mean that like how many of these
people
just don't know they're just outside
board
and then they see a group punching
someone so they run up and punch him and
they're not thinking anything
who knows i don't know i mean like
antifa would do that stuff
you know they've they would love to get
up in people's faces
i remember i mean i remember something
as simple as like when jack went to that
protest at the lincoln
i think was the lincoln statue in dc
yeah and just had you know
clearly was just being assaulted by this
random antifa kid jason charter or
whatever who ended up being arrested oh
yeah
right that was a great photo it was a
great photo but like you're just you're
just watching it and it's like this
guy's committing
crimes on camera like that's assault you
can't just push people for in like
prevent them from going places you can't
get in people's faces you can't you're
do you're committing crimes on camera
dude you're gonna get arrested for that
a friend of mine actually texted me
about caitlyn earlier today and was like
i guess people don't like
being recorded while they're committing
crimes that's yeah that's probably uh
that's probably correct serious crimes
i went to black lives matter plaza one
night um when there's a lot of people
there and it
to me seemed like they were just
randomly picking people
to kick out i i couldn't really see a
pattern of who they were picking but it
kind of seemed like
and it was a very specific group of
people it wasn't everybody there but it
was
you know a group of people and they
would just find someone who is recording
and make them leave i mean i would be
fine with like
a very serious like ramping up the
penalties for assaulting a journalist
right like five years well like how do
you define journalists in that capacity
i mean well
somebody who's like committee if if i
mean you could probably figure out a way
to do it that somebody you if you beat
up somebody who's filming you
right like in the in the in the middle
of a riot or a protest or whatever
like that's a five-year count they
chased out cnn
they did yeah you're right and cnn
didn't even mention it not
once really not once
wow they're awful
i checked the website i checked the what
shows
not juan mentioned look jeff zucker
is the reality tv guy isn't he the
apprentice guy
yeah he wanted trump wasn't that him
what he what no no
yeah he was the the apprentice guy
wasn't he i don't know i think so
cnn brought on yeah yeah double check me
double check on that one
i'm pretty sure zucker was the was the
apprentice guy or the real he was
reality tv for nbc
and cnn brought him on because they were
like listen
you know uh here's how i imagine it
you've got
uh the the executives you know time
warner whatever 18 whoever bought cnn
and they're like we don't want to do
news we just want to be bad people
what's the worst possible thing we can
do for humanity like got it
let's hire brian stelter oliver garcia
and jeff zucker to run everything
did you see the uh project veritas thing
with uh with brian stelter
yeah that was funny so for those who
haven't followed the story
project veritas got an amazing expose as
a cnn technical director basically
saying they're a propaganda network
gloating about covet death celebrating
the numbers i'm like that's insane man
yeah
i would you know what i would love talk
about sonic the hedgehog again you know
like we've done we've done segments
about like the falcon and the winter
soldier
because we really want to talk about fun
things and argue about innanities
instead of
this cnn guy gloating about all the dead
people means ratings
well so ver james o'keefe gets suspended
from twitter
they uh send a journalist to confront
brian stelter and brian stelter
in the most what's the right word
what's it's hard to say i want to say
combination of pathetic
and unwillingness to do your job and
dishonesty
is there a word for that can we make a
word for that probably a german word
we'll call it
we'll call it stealth skeleton
steltering staltering yeah it's like
rupaur
yeah yeah stealth ring so this
journalist says
you have a comment you know your
employee said your propaganda network
and he goes i feel really bad for you
and i'm like dude listen first of all
who who who explains pr to these people
you wanna if if i was confronted by
somebody don't you realize that
insulting them and yelling at them makes
everything worse for you
yeah he could have just been like i'm
not the pr person
i'm not familiar with this guy i don't
really have much to say and i'm sorry i
wish i did
right and it's like can you answer this
question honestly i really can't
right i respect that you're doing
journalism i'm sorry i don't talk to you
talk to the networks network has a pr
arm you can talk to them
i'd just be alive i'd be like look
you know um i don't really know this guy
doesn't work on my show
i'm not familiar with his opinions i
disagree with them i appreciate you guys
are trying to get to the bottom of
something you think is is malfeasance
you're gonna have to talk to cnn's
network and get a statement that's all
they can really say is that
he said he didn't say he didn't say that
at all i'm saying he should have said
that no i'm saying is all he said
i feel bad for you yes wow twice he said
it
and then he's like looking at security
and going like
what get this pro away from me
so i look at this guy um you know
uh caitlin he gets brutally beaten
in the quest to film and give the public
a view into what these people are doing
in the in the process of being beaten
he's still done that he's shown
you know the country and the world who
these people really are a lot of the
activists like to say the whole world is
watching there's a chance that a whole
lot they don't really chant it all that
much
but the world is watching and they can
see these people who
for who they are but you won't see that
you won't learn these things on cnn
because brian stalter is too busy
complaining about tucker carlson's
opinions
opinions he's allowed to have opinions
that are decently influential
opinions that only passively affect
policy
and that's his show that's cnn you have
these people at cnn who brag about being
liars
manipulators fear mongers and they're
millionaires for it i can't stand that
guy
brian stelter i and they're not a lot of
people i can't stand i'm pretty open but
like mitch mcconnell
and brian stelter i can't damn that's a
really
combination how are those guys in any
position of power
only by name recognition see did cnn's
still stealth that guy up did they
before well i mean look look for mitch
mcconnell
you know growing up as a a young turtle
in a sewer who was exposed to the earth
oh he had got the mutagen
after he after he was you know retired
he went to a life of politics and his
notoriety as a ninja turtle
really really helped him though though
uh and as for stelter
um little little known that when the
when the nintendos were
were doused in the ooze someone had
thrown uh some potatoes
into the gutter and oozed that as well i
don't
i don't really understand that's pretty
much it yeah i don't take him seriously
but that's a problem because sometimes
if you just ignore people and and
and mock them they become very dangerous
it's like in a normal world he would be
like this fringe lunatic
who'd be like struggling for any air
time he'd be like alex jones you know
you'd see him and be like oh that's a
horrible disinformation would be like
alex jones right like or treated like
alex jones is currently
exactly right because he is right like
you know actually
that no no right like i think i mean if
you that's like
i didn't i mean and i'm sorry alex i
didn't mean to you know but you could be
jerry
just by society right he'd be ostracized
by society he'd be you know struggling
to even get work
he'd be struggling to stay on platforms
uh because people would be like wow this
guy's super dishonest and spreading this
information constantly
um and i feel that way constantly like
there's so many things that the left
does
and it's like i just imagine if you were
you know i think about the kind of
lot tight rope i have to walk to keep my
platform and i'm like you guys can just
do the most absurd
fake news all the i mean the russian
bounty story like
amazing uh election disinformation right
like if the right had something like
that and it was revealed everybody who
promulgated it would have been
de-platformed
yep imagine how it works with the fact
checkers
imagine i'll tell you a story there was
a guy
uh the ap published a story there was
some guy who took credit for some action
and i said based on my investigation and
and you know i did permanent
preliminary investigation this is fake
news the ap is publishing you know
bunk information youtube deleted my
video
saying it was like a guidelines like
community violation
i don't know the exact reason because i
wasn't given a legitimate one it was you
know community guidance violation
and then two days later i think it was
or a day later the ap issued a
retraction saying we were wrong here's
what really happened and it backed up my
story and then youtube reinstated my
video
the assumption is that the ap must be
correct and tim poole random youtuber
must be wrong
meanwhile we're the ones fact-checking
the establishment they call those
gatekeepers
and they're very dangerous for a free
and open society if abc news
has an intern who writes an article that
says
ian crossland did backflip we're back on
the ian crossland does things uh
down with this backflip thing and then i
come out
as someone who knows ian and say this is
just not true
do don't defame me they will they will
the fact checkers will say
tim poole lied and published false
information abc news reported this
happened and if i would say
no tim is right abc live they'd be like
ian crossland is not a credible source
that's right
he's lying to defend himself so the
point is when
cnn nbc or abc or msnbc or any of these
outlets
make a claim it is assumed to be true no
matter what
with or without sources here's what i
love about veritas james o'keefe
literally posts a video
where it's a guy saying that that cnn is
propaganda
and they're like that's deceptively
edited meanwhile the new york times is
like a source familiar with how trump
thinks believes
that trump wants to kick a puppy and
that's like a headline story
because what some guy in an alley was
ranting about he can read trump's mind
that's fact news though remember that
video i took of the trump uh
worker being kicked out of the polling
place the poll watcher that got fact
checked into oblivion nobody ever called
me
and they the fact checks were wrong they
were all like he was let in later false
he was not
he never went back so context during uh
uh
election day you went uh you were there
and you filmed
a poll watcher being removed yeah or
being borrowed entry yeah being refused
entry into a polling place we needed
a certificate that guaranteed him that
gave him the right to enter any polling
place in
the city of philadelphia they wouldn't
let him in they wouldn't let him in
fact checkers claimed you were lying
quack checkers claimed i was first there
was one fact checker who claimed i was
i was just lying that the guy didn't
have the right to be there false
then fact checkers later claimed based
on a report you know they got a they
called the city
and the city said oh this guy was let
back in they didn't call us
i have i have a twitter account you know
like you could reach out and say like
did was he ever let back in because the
answer was no he never was let back in
oh sorry interrupt no but that goes it's
just it's just i was gonna say it's
funny to think how much people actually
lie
but it not it's not funny like i'm not
laughing about it but it's
so prevalent like i don't think about it
because i don't lie during the day
for the most part i'm honest but there
it's just so common you know why people
are scared of james o'keefe
because they're going to get caught
lying yeah and you know who's not scared
of james o'keefe me
anybody ever everybody here we've hung
out with him because the things we say
on the show are the things we say in
real life
there's no secret words like okay james
here's what we really think
no it's like i invite him on to tell him
what i really think right
yeah we all we all say our opinions i do
recognize as a problem in that
in in the digital space certain opinions
are banned and we're just happy to have
you know we're we're lucky enough to
have opinions that fall into the right
you know
area but when i'm talking with anybody
from the left or the right
i see the same things i say on here as i
say off the show the only difference is
i won't say people like i'll avoid
saying someone's name if they're like
yeah you know certain individuals to
avoid causing
you know like a brigade or something
i'll say see people say people's names
privately because it's not gonna
you know go out into the ether and then
cause someone get a bunch of emails or
something
that's about it you know a lot of people
are scared of this deception world is
crazy that like the the city would tell
say that he came back just yeah and they
didn't they didn't
check up with us i mean i think some
other poll watcher eventually went back
to that polling place but it wasn't the
one that was in the video
because i was with them all day and they
and they just reported that as like as
true without reaching out to us and
i mean the fact that the original fact
checks were wrong i mean it was just it
was really embarrassing for them even
like when you call the bank and you're
like i have an overdraft fee can you
help me they're like i can't
they're lying to you of course they can
and then if you if you push them a
little bit and say can i talk to your
manager they'll go okay hold one second
oh hello mr cross and i was able to take
that charge off i've gotta i i wanna i
wanna i wanna
i wanna talk about project veritas
because i've i mentioned this
a bit yesterday a bit earlier today but
i really do think that what they're
doing
is probably the most consequential and
important
whatever you want to call it fighting
battles that anyone in the culture war
is doing
because james is not only doing the
investigations publishing videos of
people saying these things
he's fighting the legal battles suing
the new york times
which has has uh uh let me let me ask
you this
let me let me i'll make a few more
points soon in the new york times suing
cnn now he's going to be suing twitter
he's not backing down
he is going nuclear and he's doing so
much more than anyone else is willing to
do
he's willing to just refuse to bend the
knee in any capacity
and there are so many people that i i
get mad at these cops
in the minneapolis area who can see
what's happening with show and these
other cops and they're like well i'm
going to stay here it's fine
i'm not going to stand up i'm not going
to speak out because a lot of cops did
they quit they refused
we had this story people mentioned i
think it was in denver i guess like 20
cops were like nope we out
but some of these cops are like i'll
keep my head down and say nothing james
is the opposite of that that's why i
respect him
because he's like i'm going to stand up
and scream twice as loud now
so let's let's talk about this i have a
question for you will um
in the new york times lawsuit for with
veritas the judge
said uh when he so the new york times
filed a motion to dismiss
saying that their reporters were making
opinions which are unactionable and the
judge said
if you if you have a fact-based news
story and your reporters interject their
opinions
it stands to reason you should inform
your readers of that for one i'm curious
your opinions on his ruling and what
that might mean but
does this in any way set precedent that
we could use moving forward i mean
a new york state of court opinion is is
weak precedent
generally because it's you know it's
it's a new york judge applying new york
defamation law in a new york court so
but it works for new york i mean it
probably works in federal district court
it's also not an appellate court ruling
which
really you know if you actually want
like precedent that like binds future
courts
and really influences courts far and
wide a single
state district judge is not going to do
it generally
yeah that said uh i think you know this
could go up on appeal and you can get an
appellate opinion from the new york
because i assume the new york times is
going to appeal this if they don't
settle it
and i think it could be valuable there i
think i think it's just generally i mean
it's a great opinion though and
it provides a sort of template for how
to approach these things when the new
york times does this in the future or
any other outlet does it i mean
that's a very persuasive point like you
don't get to suddenly claim you're an
opinion outlet when
you're writing a news article and then
saying somebody is deceptive and
misinforming people
i've had a lot of lawyers tell me this
that when a news article smears me
it's an opinion and i'm like how does a
someone claim to be fact-based real news
publish opinion pieces and and get away
with it without any
any accountability i mean it's you know
even then remember he just got past a
motion to dismiss
he's still got to prove actual malice i
mean he's alleged it
uh and i think there was a circumstance
where you know for some reason
uh the timing of in particular i think
it was the timing of this article and
how quickly it went up
right it was like within 63 minutes
within 63 minutes or something that was
what the judge used to infer actual
malice and infer that they didn't even
have time to try
and they still published it anyway the
new york times i think they claimed that
if you read james wikipedia that shows
that he has no
ability to sue anyone at any point
because he is
so defamed it's an interesting argument
because i get it
right the average person sees this and
assumes all of these things are true and
correct
so that brings me to the wikipedia
argument where if wikipedia is claiming
that sex
like we got very serious problems right
now
i guess the issue is james is like one
of the few people
going to war like where's everybody else
i don't know how else you
you you you know well for rally the
truth for just a little help uh pull up
bill ayers wikipedia i don't know if you
guys can do that
oh yeah but like i just from the weather
this is the weather underground
terrorist right weather underground
they're tearing around terrorists uh
excuse me will
excuse me william charles ayers is an
american elementary education
theorist oh oh yeah and he was a leader
of a militant group
described by the fbi as a terrorist
group okay that opposed your involvement
in the vietnam war
that's all they did he is known for his
1960s radical activism
and his later work in education reform
curriculum and instruction
oh he is that's what he's known for they
said
and they say project project veritas is
a far-right con
activist group that engages in
disinformation
you're talking about enrique tario the
chairman of the parabola is a far-right
neo-fascist and male only white
nationalists in political violence that
sounds right yeah
right like not setting off bombs by the
way right yeah
how many bombs says set up zero zero
it does say the next paragraph he
engaged in a campaign of bombing public
buildings including police stations the
us capital and the pentagon
secondary wow thanks for bringing that
to my attention to second paragraph
why doesn't it say william charles ayers
is a far-left
terrorist and conspiracy theorist who is
most known for engaging in terroristic
plots and insurrection against the
united states
that would be pretty accurate yeah or at
least like you got to have the same sort
of neutralizing like i mean i've seen so
many people on our side
who have wikipedia profiles that begin
just like the one about enrique tario
far right's an opinion
it's yeah it's an immediately it's
opinion saying william charles ayer is
an
american elementary educational theorist
is a fact
you can argue some of it's an opinion
like what does it mean to be a theorist
but no like he does that
yes you could also say he's a terrorist
that's also a fact also true but if you
said he was
far left far right you know or whatever
they say self-described communist you
know why because calling him a communist
could be an opinion
as a by they say he was uh you know a
founding man co-founder of the weather
underground a self-described communist
revolutionary group
they're very careful when it comes to
bill ayers with everyone else from
people like mike cernovich jack besobek
or project veritas james o'keefe
they assert a bunch of opinions they're
deceptive they're misleading they're
conspiracy theorists they're far right
none of which are statements of fact
why is wikipedia engaging in opinion
articles about people
it's 2 30 2 30 is so broad and i mean
this is actually one area where
i think i really think we could do
without 230 i mean i think
you know or very much narrow it so that
like you know wikipedia okay it has its
little
it has its pages and people can access
them if they want but if they show up on
google searches which they do then
that's wikipedia publishing them so
they're
they're now liable for whatever
difference i i i made this argument the
other day
this bill this let me let me pull up
james o'keefe
this is going to be good well we we
showed this the other day we'll pull up
we'll pull up james
it's an american conservative political
activist and provocateur what's a
provocateur that's an opinion
what has he done that's been that can be
definitively stated as as being a
provocateur
he's a journalist american journalist
the investigative journal has has james
ever called himself a conservative
activist
i don't think so i don't think he's ever
referred to himself into himself that
way
i don't think he's ever referred to
himself as an activist i mean either the
lawyers
bombed federal buildings yes james
o'keefe
filmed people saying some things they
wish they did one's a far-right activist
or they're both activists in this
respect and but one is first off defined
as being a
educational theorist so here here's the
point i brought up the other day
wikipedia right here this is whose name
is next to this statement
wikipedia in a comment section for which
section
230 is designed the username appears on
twitter
your picture and your username appears
on facebook your profile picture your
name appears
on wikipedia it says wikipedia the free
encyclopedia
james o'keefe from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia let me stop right there
the article says from wikipedia
i rest my case your honor i mean i think
you know
as i was saying before i think 230 has
been interpreted broadly enough by the
courts that it would probably
be a defense to any lawsuit based on
this stuff if so you're saying if i
write an or if i if i
publish an article if okay let's let's
slow down on timcast.com
i take the comments from people under a
video i then take the text
right put it all as an article and then
put timcast.com
this article is from timcast.com and it
says all of these insane things they
can't sue me
uh i mean it depends i mean they could
sue me but i could argue section 230
this is user generated content yeah i
mean i think you probably i mean
the way that it's been interpreted i
think you'd probably be safe i mean it's
been it's a very very broad grain of
immunity
i don't think we need it i i'm sorry
like i know it would very much disrupt
wikipedia's current model where
you know and i'm like good it's it's a
defamation engine that's what it is okay
i have a question
for anybody so 230 means that social
media
companies are not liable for what people
say on their site correct
so if you take that away wouldn't that
lead to more
censorship because if they're liable for
what people say
then take more of it off theoretically
yes
it could mean that twitter can't exist
unless twitter vets the people who are
posting
and it might revert back to everyone
having their own website which
might be something better i mean the
thing that ian and i have been talking
about
for the past i guess what three or four
weeks
is people having their own websites with
net open source networking technology
built in
so that if you have you know humane
events.com you can install this plugin
which creates a networking function
where you can choose what to exclude
from you know people who are redirected
but
it basically creates this recommendation
system so that
i'll say i definitely want to have human
events recommended in the networking tab
of timcast.com
and it creates a social media function
on my website
i mean i'd be okay with just a narrowed
230 that essentially allows twitter and
facebook to continue their current
business model
assuming they don't they knock off the
censorship and then also but also like
really puts the screws to wikipedia
right
you know because i think i think there's
something particularly damaging about
wikipedia
posturing is an encyclopedia that is
authoritative and yet it is just an
engine of defamation
it's an opinion an opinion aggregator
but but my main point is the other day i
was saying
that if you know i mentioned like your
username appears next to what you say
we say that's definitively definitively
from you what wikipedia does is it takes
the opinions
opinions literally opinions framing and
opinions of random people
but then it publishes them to a
front-facing page that says wikipedia on
top
in my opi and some of these articles
notably the james o'keefe article
is protected that means wikipedia has
decided the general public is not
allowed to edit this
only their select group of individuals
so what's defining this as user
generated
that they're not paying these people
that's it
yeah i mean well what do you think who's
who's got plenty of time
like i mean so so i can have users
three of them come over to the studio
and
i'll say anyone is allowed to to write
on this website so long as you're
a pre-approved user who's not getting
paid and they can write whatever they
want i can't be sued over it
that's that's an amazing standard the
the main issue though
is sure maybe someone argues yeah but
everything on the page is a user in the
back end
it says from wikipedia it doesn't say
from user john smith123 it doesn't say
from ian crossland it literally says
james o'keefe from wikipedia for
encyclopedia they are asserting
they are the people speaking these
statements yeah
james sue i mean well we need we need to
we need to rewrite 230 so that it
doesn't cover this like i think
how does it how could it cover you
saying i wrote this
it shouldn't i mean but if you're saying
it does i i'm pretty sure that under
current case law
it does so so what if what if i said
oh won't someone rid me of uh oh won't
someone write me this article claiming
that ian did a backflip
it's just user generated content i mean
you know maybe that's a little bit
closer to the edge because you could be
considered to be actively soliciting a
defamate defamatory content
i don't know i hope no one writes that
ian did a backflip
still same thing so what if i say we
allow
everyone to submit through the website's
forms like wikipedia
whatever they want and then we
arbitrarily just publish some of them
i don't know good question i wish i i
need to be deeper on the current 230
does not draw distinctions
no it does if you're no platform you
have specific protections but if you're
a publisher
no so those words don't appear anymore
it's like 230. what the heck
well publicly it's that you're not the
speaker of the content that's right it
says right and wikipedia is acting as a
new speaker of the company
it says it's a i'm paraphrasing but
online digital platforms cannot be held
liable for content provided by users of
that platform
and then it's it also has an extra
another provision saying it you you
cannot hold a website
responsible for the speech of its users
if they're acting in good faith to
remove lewd lascivious or otherwise
objectionable
it's it's a slight tweak on that it's
that you can't they're they're not
liable for that removal
right good faith remember is they're
also shielded from liability for that
um so they're allowed to moderate
they're allowed to remove things they
don't like
and they're allowed to
literally publish things but it's it's
it's not their opinion so it's fine
is it for any website i mean it's just
anything every network
all of them i don't think that this
should protect your computers or users
it projects it protects new york times
from their comments section no no
why wouldn't it protect an article uh an
article is like that's that's actually
the new york times
speaking right what's the difference
between the new york times
publishing an article wikipedia saying
from wikipedia uh
it's an employee of the new york times
who's actually writing the content
this is great this means we i can start
a newspaper and just not pay people
people would love to write for me and
then i can never be i mean you can just
put the pages on the website and let
people write
you know and and not well well look the
goal is like with wikipedia they put
protection on these articles so only
their select people can make changes
yeah i mean i think that that's an
interesting argument i wonder if that's
been tried
it's it's like we're deep into 230 law
now and i'm i'm not a
i am i know a decent amount about 230
but i'm not deep enough about like the
ex you know the finer points of when
something is live you protected me when
it's not
all right how about we just start a fund
raise a couple million dollars
and then just launch a volley of
lawsuits based on wikipedia claiming the
articles are from wikipedia
i mean we just let's just write some new
state laws like texas has got a great
law that that's in the book on the books
right now it basically says if you
wrongfully censor someone for their
political beliefs you're liable they can
walk into court get an injunction that's
great and get an attorney sees
but how do you how do you deal with the
the defamation machine
the defamation machine i think smear
merchants i think i think you need
you just need to amend the law that
basically says if you affirm if you
amplify
or like redirect the comments basically
what i think i think a world where
wikipedia was just a web page where
people could post
and that's all that happened right i
would i would be able to say okay
you're protected from liability for what
people post since you're just opening it
up to the world
but the moment wikipedia is redirecting
information about wikipedia entries to
google okay now you're speaking
right you're adopting these views now um
and so i don't know how to
you know i think you could probably
write a law it would be tricky to do it
but you're not going to get it at the
federal level yeah i mean
not not anytime soon so i mean maybe but
and the state law can't conflict with
federal law too so you can't
that particular law couldn't be done at
the state level right if you like
if if it conflicts with existing federal
law revolving around
uh section 230 you know federal there's
the supremacy clause right
the federal government can't legislate
everywhere but when it does state law
can't conflict with it
so i guess we need uh we we can't wait
for these laws to get passed i mean look
taxes might be doing that but
i mean you can try suits but i don't
think the suits will work right i really
think this is one of those cases
sometimes the federal government writes
a law that
you know insulates people from liability
and the only way to be able to sue them
in the future
is to get that law repealed all right so
someone needs to call ron desantis
and be like can you guys do this please
they're doing that censorship
bill they're doing a good censorship
bill i think the texas one's a little
better
texas one's a little more focused on
protecting just average citizens
the florida one was like focused on
political candidates if i remember
correctly
and didn't provide like a broad private
right of action for citizens who were
censored
um texas has got it nailed down texas is
doing it exactly right
when can we expect that do you know i
think it's working its way through the
i don't know i'm not exactly sure i it
might have passed already i don't know
they i mean i know that it was uh
governor of texas announced his support
for it
and i think it was if i got to be honest
if texas
passes that law some soon i think we
might relocate there i think it's a
strong possibility
we would we would relocate there oh yeah
i mean that would be the state where you
actually have protections now again
there's an
there's another interesting problem
which is does 230 preempt that too
because 230 says you have this liability
shield for good faith removal
and texas is saying no you don't
effectively like private citizens can
sue you if you censor their political
beliefs
now you know maybe there's no tension
there because good faith might not be
political censorship that's one avenue
but there's also justice thomas had that
opinion a few
like a week ago i don't remember exactly
what day it came out oh yeah but he made
an interesting argument that he says
actually if a if a federal law
preempts a state law that is granting
people free speech rights
the federal law has a first amendment
problem so
all right 230. interesting so 230 as
applied to try and
overturn a state law that protects
people's right to speak online
that might that as applied that might be
fall apart on a first amendment
challenge so that's i mean that
that hasn't been tested at all but like
literally that whole opinion was just
clarence thomas being like hey states
here's how you can like protect people
if you want to try
and here's some ways that this will
survive legally um interesting
you know so i need to find out more
about this because i got to be honest
you know a lot of people are moving to
texas
uh i've got you know i just did a quick
google search
texas senate committee heard legislation
on monday aiming to prohibit social
media platforms from censoring users
based on their viewpoints
senate bill sb12 filed by
senator brian hughes of mineola let's
pop this open see what we got here
introduced senate committee report and
grossed
uh i don't know what any of that means
i'll have to look into this
but uh i got to be honest like we got we
got a big operation going on here
here's the thing though if texas offers
up these protections
we have no choice but to move there you
know why my business could be shut down
overnight
yeah these platforms could just nuke us
overnight
everybody loses their jobs go to texas
we have recourse yeah i would have no
choice if this bill passes to do that
well i guess i'll need to move too i
guess we'll all need to move i think i
think most people
go to texas i i mean i you know there is
interesting things about dc
with um you know political viewpoint
political party or affiliation is a
protected class
but that doesn't do anything about big
tech no i don't think so i mean and and
this is what you know the funny thing is
i remember two years ago i've been
advocating for exactly this type of law
i was hoping we'd get it done at the
federal level but
man if we can get at the state level and
and you know we get some friendly judges
who look at it the same way thomas does
right
federal preemption of a state-created
speech right
that would be i mean that's fascinating
i mean because that would basically and
honestly it would have to
i think you know twitter and facebook
and youtube would probably at that point
stop censoring everybody because they
wouldn't want to risk somebody being in
texas and having a cause of action but
but wouldn't uh so let's say you're in
texas
they pass this bill you know the passage
it becomes law the governor signs it
you get censored and so you immediately
go into a court file
the paperwork or whatever you what would
you say you file an injunction so you so
you file a you know i mean you file a
complaint
right that's any lawsuit begins with a
complaint and then you also file a
motion for a preliminary injunction
which gives you your accounts back right
like if you win that motion you get your
account back
um that could be really quickly couldn't
it yeah i mean injunctions can get hurt
very fast like sometimes there's like
temporary restraining orders that are
super fast
um but then a preliminary injunction can
happen you know you can get a decision
on that within weeks if you want so
so let me ask let's say i'm in texas and
we're doing the show
and then one one day boom youtube's gone
so i i file a complaint and i request an
emergency
injunction because my business is now at
risk and all of my employees could be
out of work
unless this is reversed you think it's
likely a judge would say
reverse this until we can hear the case
probably probably they would probably
issue you know you'd probably win your
injunction given the nature of the law
and then then right once you win your
injection they have to let you keep your
account
until i would assume until until it's
adjudicated
now then they say but section 230 grants
us this
immunity right let's say that the
so who would hear that case would it go
to a federal court then so i mean they
could
so it depends i mean if they could
probably remove it to federal court
right like it's a there's enough money
at issue that would be what's called
diversity jurisdiction so yeah
two bases of federal court jurisdiction
this is one out what one else learned
their first day of civil procedure
okay uh two bases of federal court
jurisdiction there has to be a federal
question meaning it's a federal you're
suing under a federal law
or there's diversity jurisdiction which
means the parties are from different
states
and there's at least 75 000 at issue so
this would be a state law so it wouldn't
be a probably would be a federal
question although they might make a
first amendment claim i'm not exactly
i'd have to reread my work to think
about how that work
but it's certainly diversity so they
could remove it into federal court in
texas
so let's say in the federal court the
the judge hears it and says
i uh uh i i understand section 230
but we have a free speech issue where
the first amendment is supposed to
protect the rights of the individual and
if texas is protecting the speech rights
the first amendment can't supersede that
so i rule in favor of the complaint
right right let's they sue it goes to
the supreme court i'd imagine
if if it goes it could potentially well
there's there's i i'd actually have to
think about whether or not they'd have
the right to appeal at that point if
you've had
an injunction if you have an injunction
granted i think you probably would have
the right to appeal that right away
so let's say youtube then appeals you
you'd appeal that to the federal appeals
court so that would be the fifth circuit
court of appeals um then they would you
know have a
fairly you know fairly quick hearing on
the injunction
um and then if they lose there they can
appeal to so let let's say they agree
with you
and then they then youtube appeals again
and then it goes to supreme court yeah
supreme court they would they would
they would be applying for a stay of the
injunction now here's my final question
if the
uh supreme court agrees with me in that
case would it impact the rest of the
country
depends on how they wrote the opinion
right so if they write it in
unpublished or non-presidential it
wouldn't but they could easily
just as easily write a presidential
opinion on the injunction if they wanted
to
and then that would be binding law why
would they do one or the other
uh sometimes they they don't like
putting out presidential opinions if
it's like a very new issue they kind of
want to let lower courts handle it and
like
get more reasoned opinions also in a
rush they don't like putting out
uh because the part of the thing is
they're whenever they make a rule it
affects
everyone everything a variety different
body of law so oftentimes like
when they're forced to issue a ruling or
an opinion on
kind of short notice because it's an
injunction they are reluctant to make it
like
presidential so there are reasons you
know they want so whenever something's
presidential they want to be careful and
give it full review so there's some
reason you know
in a very very emergency circumstance
they might issue like a non-presidential
opinion
it seems it seems tough though it seems
like the likelihood
throughout the text first the texas
judge is probably gonna side with you
because the texas law says
you can't do this but then they're gonna
kick it to a federal court
and then you have what the first federal
judge the appellate and then the supreme
court
yeah and i mean probably wouldn't even
you know the i'm not sure the state
judge might grant you that immediate
temporary restraining order before the
case is removed
federal court could the federal judge
say i want to hear it state state law
stands
uh federal judge could i mean the
federal judge could maybe say there's
not even a federal court i mean it's
possible there's not jurisdiction
probably not
the federal judge would have to rule on
the injunction they could say uh
for what they could they could disagree
right they could say first amendment
doesn't apply we're denying your
injunction
then you could appeal um or vice versa
they could
they could go either way interesting so
basically texas is granting you the
right to
this platform to speak and this the
federal government have to deny you that
right
right exactly which is sort of and there
and there's precedent in different
contexts where not not in the tech
context but it's like in the union
stuff there's some there was some
supreme court case where the supreme
court said something like
if a federal law preempts a state
right that grants the right to speak
that's a first amendment issue
and there's a first amendment
prohibition against that i wonder if if
you were suing youtube for instance in
texas
but if youtube's like a delaware
corporation then with that
and you were in texas would that
automatically be across state lines and
immediately become a federal
depends so this is another classic 1l
simple procedure issue which is a
corporation is located in its principal
place of business in its place of
incorporation for diversity purposes so
google's a you know primary place of
business in california delaware
corporation
so if you are a resident of either
delaware or california
it would diversity jurisdiction wouldn't
be available but if you were resident of
texas yeah it would
man i think there's an easier solution
to this i think ian you're saying in
three months we can have this thing up
and running
that was one person mentioned that if we
had 10 dedicated full-time developers
that can't be ready for 30 months
that's like optimal pie in the sky i
think three months but
yeah something i mean within the year
for sure i would imagine but what if we
got like a hundred
you know open source community active
communication in a discord server
it would be good we're getting close to
that but there are diminishing returns
when people code over each other
and forking yeah too many cooks in the
kitchen so you wanna you wanna crack
team of like
experts and specialists so what what i
want to do
is i want to make it that there's one
big thing that makes youtube dominant
and that's you make money on youtube
there's a reason why people don't use
these other platforms
people get banned from youtube and
they'll say okay fine i'll now i'll go
to mines.com
but you make money on youtube now mines
was smart about this
and they implemented a way to make money
on mines as well and the tokens actually
worth like three bucks now so
yeah so i i haven't uh you know all my
videos automatically post on mines and
everything
but for most people they need to make
money so we want to make a way
that you can have an open source piece
of software free for everyone that makes
it very easy
to install a website you buy server
space
boom you install it it's a functioning
website where you can easily post things
wordpress already makes it particularly
easy so
we're also going to provide instructions
and for people because there's some
you know learning curve but it includes
subscription functionality
so that somebody can you you can easily
plug in if you're using paypal stripe or
some other you know ecommerce platform
then you have a members only so you can
isn't ghost doing something like this
because it's this sounds similar to
substance
but ghost i think except this is going
to be you
on your server with your domain however
you do it
you own it and no one can ban you but
yourself that's ghost i'm pretty sure i
don't know if you guys are familiar with
the host i'ma look them up though yeah
it exists yeah i think it might exist
already so you like
drop drop it onto your server and boom
and then you got it right right good
like because
i know if you know bellagi uh srinivasan
he wrote about this right he was like
writing about like how you know after
twitter censorship how do you do this
and he was like
there's a sub stack is still centralized
right substances
but ghost is like something you
implement on your own whatever the
website is
uh i think let me see because if i
google search ghost i'm not going to
find it yeah right
now it's not that hard
but but listen listen there's one other
thing maybe they've edited this
ghost.org if you want to find that we we
want to add a
networking functionality because the
next big thing about youtube
is that it markets you for you
instead of buying marketing like a
traditional show if youtube likes you
and thinks they'll make money off you
they'll start promoting your
work so what we want to add to these
websites is a networking section that's
that's part of the package
now you'll have on your site the ability
to remove certain people so they won't
appear on your site
certain words phrases or things it's
your choice but it's your website
mm-hmm so then if i go to if someone
goes to samecast.com
then this software allows people to
comment be users
it's connected to the fetaverse so the
networking section functions like chat
rooms or twitter
but then they can also see recommended
shows that are very similar based on
keywords
so it'll be like human events and you
know carl benjamin lotus eaters podcast
and then they'll be like oh cool and
they can get that recommendation feed
like they would on any other platform
but it's a decentralized network of
people just running these sites i was
just thinking
a cool feature would be if you opted in
for your site to be found on other
sites then tim could put my site on his
site and if someone found me through
tim's site
tim would get five percent of the
revenue so you would be able to opt into
that
it's not ghost ghost is a free trial
service sign up
it's like you get 14 days free trial i'm
talking about we would give you
there's like a plug-in oh it's like free
it's just totally free absolutely free
for everybody
and you own it 100 it's open source code
it's just free to use
when you open it boom all of a sudden
your website has like a post section for
you you log in you just like click a
post like you would be on twitter or
whatever you upload a video
and then you can click a lock button and
lock it and say five dollar members only
and then people can click become a
member you'll need your own accounts
maybe paypal bans you maybe stripe bans
you maybe your domain bans you well
those are other services you can't get
around but there won't be a patreon ceo
who bans you
there won't be a jack conti who bans you
and then in or
in order to see ceo of patreon in order
to then
network with other people it's in the
fetiverse the federal verse for people
don't know is basically like a twitter
protocol
where different servers can communicate
with each other so you could follow
someone on gab
but also see them on a different server
a different website all out all together
so then we basically create probably the
way it should be
if we do that we don't need section 230.
that's true i mean i really would like
to create a world where we just
that these people are irrelevant right
like i think that's the end goal and i
mean i'm i'm all for it i'm not a tech
guy i don't know tech i know law
and so i'm just like okay how do i use
how do we change the law to solve the
problem
that's my you know that's my role i hope
you guys can solve it via tech
i think can't legislate away every
problem that's for sure that's true but
i mean you know some
people i i still have a pro like people
underestimate
how effective law can be solving at
particular types of problems you know i
mean we've
we've got a lot of there's a lot of
background for how to solve common
carrier type problems and discrimination
type problems i mean that's
that's the whole thing clarence thomas
wrote about you know he wrote you know
went through you can make big tech comic
carrier you can make them
have public accommodation laws and and
then you create private rights of action
like you don't you don't need a
bureaucracy to solve civil rights like
you literally can just do it through
people
litigating very briefly how do you feel
about legislating gun rights like saying
limiting people's gun rights when there
are 3d printers that can print those
weapons in secret
i mean i i basically think i'm a
constitutionalist on that
i think you know peller is right we
shouldn't you know
guns that are in common you shouldn't be
regulated uh
i think you know i mean i'm not a i
guess i wouldn't say i'm an absolutist
in the sense that i think all current
gun laws are
unlawful or something via the second
amendment because i think even at the
time of the founding there were some
some restrictions out there and i think
i mean i remember there was some stuff
you were saying about like
for example i think it's okay to
prohibit like violent felons from owning
guns
right like i i'm okay with that law i
disagree with it
what gets me is when they try and say
it's illegal to have this kind of gun
but then it can be 3d printed in
someone's basement
like you can't yeah i can't back that
like you can't enforce that law so
yeah it's bad to have laws that are
unenforceable in general
uh i don't like unenforceable laws um
but
you know i mean i saw you were like you
were you were going through the dante
right case and be like that person
shouldn't have been arrested or whatever
for the country well but there was also
the aggravated robbery which is a
different story
right well i mean but yeah like my view
is okay so the guy gets out
you know he's he's arrested for
aggravated robbery and indicted and
trial dates in two years well we want to
give him bail okay but he's been
indicted for aggravated robbery
like i think it's a reasonable condition
of bail that you do not possess a
firearm at that point
yeah i agree right right right my
position is
after they get out of prison and we're
like you've paid your debt to society
they get their rights back
i think i think that's more defensible
but i still i'm still okay with laws
that say like certain
you know violent felonies if you
committed a violent felony you you
forfeit that right in the same way that
you
four foot of voting right i think you
should have the right to vote
if you're in prison maybe not uh if
you're in prison you obviously don't get
a gun
but if you're out like i i just don't
like the idea of second class citizens
for any reason i agree you
you people have to be brought back in
and we have to give people the
opportunity
because when the problem with these
felony laws i'll tell you a story i i
worked at this uh
i worked at a smoothie shop once and
this this woman who worked there
apparently was like
telling so i i overheard this so i could
be wrong it's been like 15 years
a woman applied for a job and
on the application she said that she was
a felon and her felony as she explained
it was that
she was arrested for sleeping in an
airport she was there she overstayed her
ticket and she remained in the airport
so they
eventually arrested her with a felony
for being in an airport without a ticket
something like that
and then they gloated about how they
would not hire her and they were like as
if we would hire that person
and i'm like she's trying to work a
minimum wage job selling smoothies dude
yeah no i mean i that's a different
actually a different issue where i'm
like totally okay with certain
government programs to like subsidize
the hiring of people
it's it's it's not it's not necessarily
what i what you know but just what i
mean i'm just saying
if someone knows no matter what i do i
am going to be a second class citizen
why why yeah why would they bother
reforming themselves or trying to come
back in society
and doing better they can't travel they
can't
you know have a weapon they can't defend
themselves they can't vote they're not
they're not
no taxation without representation i
don't care if you've if you can if
you're if you're out of jail if
the judge says your punishment for doing
this will be 10 years
then after the 10 years then we're like
welcome back
now don't do it again and you'll enjoy
the fruits of
american citizenship but if you're a
second class citizen you're much more
likely
in my opinion to do it again i agree so
then you have more people in jail
because you view yourself as an outsider
at that point you're like i'm not a part
of your system i'll do what i want and
if you can't get a job
then it's you know i mean that seems i
mean i would focus on the job part i
just don't think
you're entitled to vote at that point i
don't think that i mean i'm also more of
a
utilitarian when it comes to voting i
don't like you know
then i'll say this shall not be
infringed
yeah but shall not kill should 13 year
olds 13 year olds be able to
allowed to buy guns no shall not be
infringed
in in this in 1789 were there 15 year
olds who owned their own property and
were
you know running like there are still
those possession laws right for example
rittenhouse i mean
he like i'm pretty sure i know they're
trying to prosecute him for unlawful
possession of that firearm but my
reading of the law says it was lawful
yeah yeah i've i've heard some other
experts talk about this now let me
clarify too i'm actually just giving a
very
harsh interpretation of 2a i don't think
13 year olds should be allowed to buy
guns or have guns
i think there should be um it is
difficult though and the reason i say
this is back then
you know way back when the the age
limits were much lower for a lot of
things
we've moved them up repeatedly 18. it
was it was
so we set it at 16 and then it's 18 now
it's 21 they're trying to make it 21 in
some places
eventually it'll be 30 eventually to be
35. so the champion
i non-ironically think we should raise
the voting age to 30.
is there a constitutional amendment that
says the right to voting shall not be
infringed for any persons in the united
states
i don't think so there's a there was
there was a constitution a late
constitutional amendment that reduced
the
i think the voting age to 18 for
everybody there there are i think three
three amendments it's voting age uh
women and um
on race i believe yeah so but we just
need to revise that one that's made at
18 just make go ahead
we're not going to get that that that uh
constitutional amendment anytime soon
i was so excited anyway let's read super
chats
my friends time thanks for hanging out
on this friday and i don't know many of
you probably want to be out you know
drinking and partying cleveland but
you're here listening to the
uh very important conversations over at
team casterl so i
greatly appreciate it if you haven't
already smash that like button
and comment because it really does help
your you're basically you know the
engagement is a great thing
and we appreciate it and if you're
listening on itunes or spotify leave us
a good review give us five stars
go to timcast.com become a member and uh
excuse me we're gonna have a bunch of
really awesome uh content coming up in
the future
new shows we're in the process of
reviewing new hires so we've got
uh i shouted this out yesterday a
paranormal and mysteries writer
which will be a part of the podcast show
and a news editor and a fact checker
we're going to have a
an in-house fact checker who will be
despised by everybody because
they're not they're not going to hang
out they're going to be isolated they're
going to be like internal affairs
yeah but uh we're we're in the process
of of going through these new hires not
so easy to just like grab a random
person like you're hired we gotta
check for skill do interviews make sure
people are cool and you know
able to do the job so yeah go to
timecast.com let's read some super chats
and smash that like button if you
haven't christian
uh jam gocheon says i work at a small
business and i just found out that one
of my co-workers watches your content as
much as i do
so i'm finally able to talk politics
with someone who respects free thought
awesome hey you're glad to hear it
good stuff john lee says hey tim when is
the chicken stream starting and is it 24
hours
yes and soon you see the chickens we
have outside
no they're getting so big so fast
growing fast bring chickens
okay we had eight unfortunately two
didn't make it
they were uh they succumbed to the worm
i was listening to some podcast by ryan
holiday and he was talking about if you
on a farm you get much more familiar
with death broadly because like
you own chickens and they die they had
parasites
and we immediately uh went to a vet
was provided with medicine and the
medicine wasn't enough
it's just too late you know we called
the the chicken farmer guy who we bought
from and he's like look
sometimes there's there's weak chickens
they don't make it and you
it's you try everything and and so we
were sad
you know two of them didn't make it but
these these ones we have that are six
are awesome
well one of them almost died so so they
were getting sick and um
when we we tried we started giving
medicine two didn't make it so we
immediately
one of them that looked like it may be a
little sick we immediately started
giving it the medicine
and it's smaller than the rest because i
think it would have died if we did not
give it that medicine
but uh we're going to be setting up a
series of cameras it's going to be 24
7 live chickens
chickens that's right absolutely it's
called the chicken city well according
to this
article about from peta chickens are
arguably the most abused
animals on the planet not ours not yours
i'm glad you're taking care of these
yeah we're gonna we're gonna have them
lovely ladies
we're we're gonna get the eggs from them
it's gonna be fantastic we're gonna have
a camera
a camera on the on the chicken city 24
7.
and they're hilarious little things uh
they're smart enough to know not to
drink their water
water that's full of feces but they're
not smart enough to not
take a dump in their water so it's like
yeah so so andy who who does the
construction stuff around here he was
like they're right in that sweet spot
where
they won't drink the water with the crap
in it but they're not smart enough to
not crap in their water
so it creates problems do you build like
a a drinking thing like at neck level a
little higher
yeah maybe well what we're going to do
is we're going to create uh we have a
night
we have some ideas for a water system
that will automatically
funnel like flush through yeah it'll be
at an angle oh yeah so if they dump in
it it'll it'll float down
and the water coming at the top will
always be cleaner
and but you got to just change their
water and give them food and you know
for the most part they take care of
themselves they walk around eating bugs
and they eat grass a lot
and they destroy everything else yes
they do it's gonna be great but we also
we also have the chicken city connected
to our garden
cool so what you do is in the springtime
you let them into the garden and they
tilt
they till the ground for you they
scratch it looking for bugs and then you
get all this loose dirt and then you go
and you plant your
new plants all right let's see what we
got
in some chats gouda says when doge
crashes and lots of people
lose their money crypto will be heavily
regulated it will hurt the industry
um i don't think so there's a there's a
funny comic it's a cyanide and happiness
and it was it was an age-like milk on
reddit and it was someone getting
it's like a guy's robbing somebody hey
you give me all your money and the next
panel
max panel is he goes i don't have any i
only use bitcoin and then the robber
goes you need this more than i do and
handed a bunch of money to him
because in 2014 bitcoin went like 20 20
grand and then dropped down
to like some really people lost their
houses
people were taking out like loans to buy
bitcoin and then yikes that's just a bad
idea and here's the best part
the people who panicked and sold are
probably crying right now you could have
held it
it's at 63 000 i mean the smart
investors knew
i know it dropped i'm going to hold it
until it's back the worst is
i don't know anything about bitcoin or
cryptocurrency but there's apparently
like
the keys where you can get into your
money but there's people who lost them
and there's no way to get them back
yeah and so i was reading this article
and it's it's guys in there who have
this one guy was like yeah i have two
million dollars in bitcoin just a normal
guy
he's like i can never get it it's like a
special kind of yeah you get like 10
tries
and then it self destructs and he was on
like try number eight
yeah and had no idea like that sucks
and then the entropy makes the value of
the like
those those coins are basically out of
circulation they're going to be used so
there's less bitcoin than it looks like
so which means they're actually more
valuable than
the numbers say interesting it affects
trade volume
all right powder pz says tim just want
to let you know that scar the scarlet
witch is a bad guy
she's going to be the villain in the
upcoming doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is that confirmed
because that sounds really awesome
huh yeah there there there was a post by
bruce campbell
where it was on april 1st so nobody
thinks it's real
probably an april fool's joke where it's
a script from doctor strange where
doctor strange goes to evil dead
and he sees uh ash who's got you know
chainsaw arm or whatever
and then he's like i'm looking for the
dark hold and then he's like what's the
name like it's a book and he goes have a
face on it
and then dr strange is like what because
you know you've seen evil dead right
the necronomicons got a face on it or
whatever something like that i don't
know whatever if they start
i have no idea what you're talking about
at all you are not a man of culture will
they'll if they start crossing doctor
strange i'm sorry
very offended i appreciate it i think
the best thing disney could do is start
crossing doctor strange to every disney
story that they can i don't know if they
own dark tower or not but benedict
cumberbatch is such
a good actor possibly one of the best
actors on earth maybe
what i think his top top three actor in
my opinion
that that he could cross over in any
genre and it would be
the doctor strange character he's
amazing as doctor strange he's fantastic
it's it's it's it's brilliant i thought
it was awful as julian assange it was
the
weirdest trash i've ever seen yeah i was
just like
what it's a big role very weird and like
so i've met a song jen i'm like
with i don't know i don't think it's
cumberbatch's fault wrongly cast
first thing no no no the writing of like
what they view assange to be just so
seems like
makes no sense did you see uh star trek
when he played khan
i liked it yeah he was incredible i
didn't know who he was when i saw that i
just was like
but people were mad because it was uh
who was it ricardo maltobon is that his
name
montabon montabon or something i don't
know he played khan in the original
movie
so then they like you know now they have
this tall white dude
everyone got mad all the people that
time
he was very intense all right wayne
smith says quote the fbi has made an
average of more than four arrests a day
seven days a week since january 6th says
acting deputy attorney general john
carlin
they can do it for the capital but can't
do it for looters and riots
that's right yeah well we're you mean
embrace the fact that you're
second-class citizens all ready you know
jeez yeah kind of
yep all right voltage uh voltage volt
says hello everyone of the beanie
compound i finally subscribed to the
website right before the show started
been watching for about two years now
haven't missed a show love you guys
awesome nice we have a massive library
of content
so if you go to timcast.com we have this
new streamlined members area when you
click it
you actually can see just scroll down
very easily all of these different
subjects that you can you can watch
some of these are like an hour long
we've got we've got one with um james
o'keefe it's an
hour where it's like it's like a full
podcast episode so that's
just part of the members only stuff so
go go become members check that out
all right turk longwell says tim i
mentioned in a lefty chauvin youtube
live stream about giving 16 year old
guns with their driver's licenses
they hated the idea and called me sick
2a right
you know what's interesting hardcore
leftists are very pro-2a
and i think it was vosh who was tweeting
that
in the event things fall apart it stands
to reason you don't
only want the right-wing militias to be
armed yep so you probably
leftists should probably want to have
guns so that's a really good point yep
well i mean that's that's why they're
underground too like again i've read
this i read this whole book about
days of rave which i can recommend by uh
bill burrows i think
and and something that you know bill
ayers like was famous for being in front
of like a weather underground conference
and he's like do you guys own a gun
do you not understand what's coming like
the whole idea is they're revolutionary
communists they thought they wanted to
do cuba here and so they're like of
course we want
guns yeah that's important the problem
is they're allied
with the establishment left and the
establishment left
thinks guns are like nuclear bombs
it's the craziest thing you know i
really i genuinely believe
if you've got somebody who's like i'm a
gun owner and guns should be banned
that's a grifter that's absolutely a
grifter because if they've actually held
a weapon and know anything about it they
know
the democrats are wrong or lying and
they have no idea what they're talking
about
when someone says oh you know i i was in
the i was in the marines and i had a gun
and we shouldn't give weapons of war to
people it's like okay i know you're
grifting because that means you know
an ar-15 is not an m16 you have no idea
those people are almost always like some
back office
types in the you know they were like
jags yeah yeah yeah
and so then you have the rest of these
people i'm confident
they've never held a weapon in their
life just not not even i wonder if
they've even held like a super soaker
it's not part of the culture
like it's just there's a big cultural
difference i mean and
i think that's something that liberals
really struggle with the idea
it's completely alien to them that guns
would be something like you you go with
your kids you hunt you
target shoot it's like part of the way
the way i described it is when i cross a
busy street
i'm not worried about getting hit by a
car you know there's cars driving all
crazy and you're walking
there's a stop sign you really think
that that sign
which is just a representation of an
idea will stop someone from slamming
into in that car
yes because people don't want to kill
you so when i see someone walk around
with a gun
i'm not worried about them trying to
kill me yeah but you've got to look both
ways because those stops
won't stop a car that's right so when
you're walking near people you don't
know or trust you have to be aware of
your surroundings at all times doesn't
matter if it's a car or a guy with a gun
and if you're going to use a gun
or a lady with a gun you better know how
to use it yeah better be trained
all right david norman says blocking
traffic during a protest is a violation
of the non-aggression principle
interesting true agreed the libertarians
found something they're right about
uh congratulations uh but they are quite
correct
and uh that's why they should go to jail
for doing that
all right vbdc says bill ayers also
wrote rules for radicals
well that was solinski wasn't it that
i'm pretty sure that was alinsky i know
i mean
ayers wrote some things but i don't he
didn't write rules for radicals he might
have written some like
it's possible he wrote something for
radicals but yeah
that's not that was a linsky which i
think most people should read um
i think you know olinsky dedicated it to
satan i think is the first radical
yeah and i just see that as uh maybe i'm
in my harry potter i'm a little rusty
but it's like a horcrux
it's something designed to everything
it's something designed to prevent like
conservatives from reading it like they
see them like oh they're
terrible horcrux preserves the soul of
the person so they can't die
okay well then i have no idea what i'm
talking about all right
but yeah interesting it repels them yeah
imran says tim stop spreading
disinformation
firearms policy coalition is going after
nyc
and chicago's de facto gun bans oh
they're already going to court for nyc
and they're building their chicago case
well there you go very neat glad someone
is doing it
ted 2 says tim check out the channel
ranger up
video they make a weekly news segment
that's legit and more people should see
it veteran company that started out
making t-shirts you should have nick and
matt on the show
would be great conversation we will look
into their channel
all right let's see we will find
some uh stephen a says i made a bunch on
the holy doge so here's a tie to the
high priest of the beanie
i love my gorilla shirt it's super soft
awesome legit yeah
teespring has really great uh shirt
quality yeah notice it was soft
i love it yeah he was impressed remember
if you're making money on doge that you
need to
you need to declare all that stuff as
capital gains oh yeah
for tax purposes well if you sell it if
you sell it right
yeah if you receive doge from someone
you've already gained
so that's where it gets interesting i
wonder how that would work like let's
say let's say you know you give me a
doge right
and it's worth five cents at the end of
the year it's now worth 50 cents
do i owe on 50 cents or five cents you i
mean you own five cents it's the value
of i mean i'm pretty sure when you
value the gift when it was given uh okay
right like but then if you sell it your
value you have to
pay taxes on the gain read number two
says i don't care how peaceful you are
blocking traffic you're still halting
everyone's right to travel without being
unreasonably stopped
that's a civil rights violation so a
felony charge is perfectly suited to
that i just love how the commentators
are totally supporting my side of this
debate this is fantastic
see we it's a war we're open to
differences of opinion yeah i got mixed
feelings because i agree with you
but i also acknowledge the united states
is an act of civil disobedience
right you know this is sort of the
dilemma i mean this is the hamilton
dilemma right hamilton really quickly
realized like hey you know we can't just
be revolting all the time people
actually do need to respect waffle
authority
and you know that's i mean it's not now
that we've removed the king
everybody must stop revolting because
i'm in charge now and must respect me
no he's not a tyrant yeah but i mean he
you know he's oh he's second in command
you know he was a
hamilton basically built the federal
government like yeah we sort of
underestimate that but
the primary author of the constitution
responsible for many of the early
departments and and
brilliant like the plan for
manufacturers and economics i mean
brilliant guy um but yeah i mean he was
you know he was sort of a half
monarchist in his own way
and anyway so i i'm a big believer in
law and order so yes we are founded on
revolution that's great like we don't
want to have revolutions every week
right stephen sherman with a massive
super chat says
you are a republican you just know don't
know how our freedom works together
now do you mean like little are
republican as in like the republic or
the political party because i'm not a
fan of the republican party yeah
not either well so i remember still i i
always chuckle because i remember we had
like a conversation before we did one of
our shows like a youtube show a couple
years ago
we had a conversation where you're like
well you know it seems like we agree on
everything and yet you're a trump guy
[Laughter]
and then and then you you became a trump
guy so yeah but
the the city the issue was trump
released a comprehensive list of things
he was
he was going for yeah and i was like i
can get behind that
that's good i mean that's all true i
don't know like i was always
you know i've i've my view over you know
i can be annoyed at the republican party
but at the end of the day like
i i don't think it's responsible to let
democrats have power if it can be
avoided
that's true i get that but i think my my
bigger point was that
on the issues that are relevant today in
politics we mostly agree that's true
but even though there's probably a wide
range of things we completely disagree
like we disagree today on
you know that's true on the protest
stuff like i have a
fairly lefty view on the protest stuff
that's true and it's interesting how
when you're honest and you understand
the truth and you're like
we actually know when the news is lying
so there's no issue when we're like oh i
disagree oh okay
the issue is when the left believes
things that aren't true and you confront
them with the truth and they lose their
minds because of it or they don't want
you to say things that can
conflict their world view or they're
just bigoted i mean that's a big problem
that i see i mean just people losing
friendships people disowning their
family i mean that's that's cult stuff
you know it's
we were watching a lot of the
scientology and the aftermath um
the leah remini show and and you know
scientology has
gets all this flack for disconnection um
which is the policy but like somebody
leaves the church their whole family
needs to disconnect from them
and i'm like this is what woke liberals
do like liberals watch the show and like
oh that's crazy i would never do that
also like i disowned my racist uncle for
being a racist this is this is the
problem
there are a lot of people who are like
i'm a big fan of the show and i'm like
prominent people was like why don't you
come on well i mean look i work with a
lot of people
and i'm like dude do you really want to
live that way
i'm sorry i'm sorry hold on i'm not
entirely sure how you really could be a
fan of the show
if you're also unwilling to actually
just stand up for yourself and say
i just happen to like the show there's
nothing more freeing than being in this
space honestly like at least
you know i have to worry about twitter i
have to worry about somebody else but at
the end of the day like
i don't worry i don't have to worry that
i'm going to say something that leads to
me being fired and i don't have to worry
about saying something that
you know i just can say what i think the
thing is for most conservatives that
come on the show
this show is leftward for them no
conservative is going to be like will
why are you talking to tim poole don't
you know he was yelling about taxing the
rich
what are you doing man you're no
conservative will do that
conservatives will come here and be like
i think you're wrong and i'm like i
think you're wrong like well
that was fun yeah but if we go
if you know if we cross that line into
the tribal left or i should i'm sorry if
the tribal left crosses the line in this
direction to
rightward then they get harassed and
berated and attacked
and they're scared i mean the funny
thing is they probably sorry i'll let
you go
just one last point they would probably
say like how dare you give tim pool a
platform yeah
which is like the most hilarious thing
yeah well because for them they say
things like
oh speeches this speech is violence
exactly it is literally not
like that is quite literally untrue yes
but like
quotes and sayings like that when you
actually believe stuff like that then it
does become
unacceptable behavior to go on timpal's
show
there there is one way that speech can
be violence
if it's really loud screaming it's wrong
i hate loud bars like does anybody else
hate it's violence like silence
no but if you like got called someone
and screamed the second amendment over
and over again
into their ears as loud as possible
you're not the one screaming okay
your speech is hurting somebody literal
violence literally yeah
all right cory exception corey hill ooh
this is important says tim
we have been trying to reach you about
your car's extended warranty oh
you should have you guys been getting
those calls you should answer that yes
yes why
i was just kidding no when they call me
i go which one
i have to get in there i've been getting
some call i usually delete it after the
first three seconds damn likely
rustling says hey tim ian sb 519 in
california is going to legalize dmt
this is weird because i am on the fence
with this bill wow
that's so weird that california's like
we will lock you up for the stupidest
things
but you can smoke drugs sb519 yeah
controlled substance decriminalization
so it's not legalizing it but it looks
like it's decriminalizing it
right right which means you can have it
you won't go to jail so we're going to
learn like tomorrow joe rogan announces
he's moving back to california
california is just just going straight
to mad max right like just endless
homeless encampments they're not going
to do a thing about them
and then you can do whatever drugs you
want yeah wow
it is psychedelics are way different
than amphetamines though so
yeah i'm kind of down through that i i
don't have a strong view on whether dmv
dmt should be have you ever smoked it
nope it's amazing
i've only smoked a little bit but
apparently when you talk to people that
go deep
it's the one spiritual yeah ayahuasca
oh is dmt ayahuasca is the same thing
ayahuasca causes your body to produce
large amounts of dmt
uh-huh that's where that experience
comes from okay interesting vbdc says
by the way kailyn from from scriber was
on your show yes
lydia said we know him one of our
friends that's why we wanted to talk
about him getting brutally beaten
because
that was the context of the segment
here's a guy who's willing to go on the
ground and actually risk his safety to
get his information versus cnn
who surround themselves with security
guards while complaining about guns and
lying to people so it's like
inverted yes sorry having him on with a
bruised
beat up face i don't want to objectify
you kalin i'm not doing that but i mean
having having someone on that has
experienced physical trauma like
so you can see the effects would have
like uh more of an impact
youtube might take that down yeah that's
what i'm wondering yeah youtube says you
can't show
like violence what's it called yeah but
i i think they wouldn't take that one
down
real hard actually this is really
interesting youtube just relaxed their
rules
there was a big announcement that as of
the 15th you're allowed to
have some swearing moderate profanity
uh at a certain point or the other it's
weird but you're actually allowed now to
show
violent interactions with police
officers oh wow like straight up you can
show it you can monetize it now that to
me was crazy i was like
but you know we're letting that cost
again yeah i love the show no no
no but let's listen the issue i think
was that
a lot of leftist activists were getting
demonetized
for showing dante writer dante wright or
or adam toledo
and so youtube was like okay okay fine
fine fine you can do these now
cool interesting yep fine castle i.e
says congrats on the one million tim and
cast since our pillow was a success
would you ever sell a t-shirt called our
gorilla with the gorilla wearing a
beanie holding a hammer and sickle
maybe we're trying to we're trying to
figure out i am a chimpanzee full of
snakes
yes but i think that's a jordan peterson
well hold on sheamus of freedom tunes
made a joke about it
jordan peterson apparently said
something this effect where uh
i i guess james pointed out that inner
lecture peterson said
like what are you even anyway you're a
chimpanzee full of snakes or some
approximation of that
yeah so then he did a the jordan
peterson is the red skull joke
where the avengers are watching red
skull lecture and he says what are you
you're a chimpanzee full of snakes
so then we said on the show everyone
laughed and they're like make a t-shirt
but maybe sheamus should make the
t-shirt because that'd be cool
perfect yeah you know that'd be fun i'd
hawk his merch heck yeah yeah
it's probably a shirt he should he
should be selling chimpanzee full of
snakes
what's bizarre look man i think jordan
peterson's great
but a lot of people who are passive
viewers of him don't realize he says a
lot of things that you would absolutely
be
be baffled by unless you have contact
yeah without the full context of his
lectures
like the the snakes and the i just
sheamus really really gets it yeah it
hurt it never struck me
all right brown bear says if i'm stuck
in traffic because of a bunch of
protesters decided to protest the middle
of the street
i immediately hope whatever their cause
is fails no matter what it is
i agree with that yeah yeah absolutely
yeah it's selfish i mean
it's fundamentally a very selfish way to
protest it's just indifferent
to other people inflicting pain on third
parties who have nothing to do
with your protest pr suicide yeah
jail all rights christopher cabey says
tim are the chickens getting a youtube
channel we did mention this the answer
is yes
it is going to be called the chicken
city or something to that effect we
don't know the full name so
um but uh we have the the for we we
double fortified
the chicken city so we used to just have
one layer of like chicken wire and then
we we doubled over it with uh with a
stronger uh metal
and we want to make sure so we added
another latch to because
we had someone try something try to
break in i think it was like maybe a
raccoon
so we set a trap and you know we have to
put some lights up motion sensor lights
to scare it off
doesn't work yeah it doesn't work it
doesn't help yeah they're bold 24 7 live
stream
there you go yeah just running
permanently i'm looking through my
mentions and
i tweeted about the video and somebody
said to tell tim to fire ian hashtag
fire ian no not happening no they're
saying ian's fire
that's right all right all right let's
see what we got here we got fire
nicknast says hey all i was listening a
few days ago and heard ian mention he
was looking for a php
developer for the open source project i
emailed info and jobs at timcast but got
a reply
should i contact ian directly if so
what's a good contact email
um you message me on twitter that seems
to work yeah
do i follow you either on twitter i no
you sure should definitely
uplifting air traffic controllers says
the texas house passed a law making open
carry legal even without a permit
come on down to texas that's a pretty
good reason
i follow you ian but you don't follow
[Laughter]
chris rose 1986 says we need to change
the 13th amendment there should be no
slavery at all
all felons that have done their time
should have all their rights back the
pink gorilla t-shirt is great
don't don't tell that to joe biden who
said that no amendment is absolute
yeah right like you know all those
exceptions to the 13th amendment that
need to be made
all right white metal baby says tim it's
time announce your intention to form a
new independent media center dedicated
to true and valuable context opinion
dibs on first name chicken media or is
that is that a rooster or a turkey i
can't tell it's a chicken oh it's a
rooster oh oh rooster rooster media i
like it well now you can't use the name
because it was his idea which means
he'll come and sue you for coffee
good idea though all right waffle sensei
says will is correct about not voting
while having a felony
the felony will come off your record
eventually and if we expect
immigrants to follow the law to get in
we should expect citizens to follow
higher classified laws to vote on those
laws
when you're wait wait wait wait is there
a period after
you leave prison as a felon you get your
voting rights back um i mean i think if
your felony is expunged
yeah but how do but not that's that's
like some felonies don't get expunged
i assume most don't i don't know i don't
know the details of that but
uh that's not you know i don't i don't
rely on his rationale for saying why
uh felons shouldn't have voting rights
hey look at this sterling morris says
tim look up
chicken nipple waterer no joke they are
top-down waterers they can't crappin
i will i will i will get that i will
look that up right after the show and we
will have good waters they
understand chickens
robo cheezit says i will watch this
later but i love the show so thank you
but tim i'm curious would you go around
uh go around your of video calls
if you could have edward oh your rule
would i have video calls if i could have
edward snowden on
no i wouldn't but robo cheese it your
name is sweet
i love it no exceptions demaco says tim
what are you back when you're going back
on joe rogan probably never
um simply because i am dedicated to
making this project work
timcast.com is growing we've got a ton
of work we have to do and i have no time
for for for anything uh so
rogan's podcast is fantastic robin's an
awesome dude a big big big
big fan but i get a lot of requests
there are some shows that i've done
where it's like i can turn the camera on
when i'm already here and just talk for
like 10 minutes
hiring people is hard work we have so
many resumes
and there's a lot of people who email us
who have no experience
and are like you know i work in a
warehouse but i can totally do this i
swear and it's like look man
uh i'm glad you guys are interested i'm
glad you're fans but it's really
difficult to quality control everything
and we we literally can't hire someone
who doesn't know how to do a job to do a
job
it's hard enough because we're not joe
rogan level we don't have that kind of
money
so we're trying to get top level people
at
premium rates essentially and it's very
difficult if we want to make this work
we're going to need some talented free
thinking individuals who
are the best of the best at what they do
or to the best of our ability
the best based on how much we can afford
to spend so it's tough it's not it's not
it's not easy
i should say i'm not specifically
looking to hire a php
developer i want to get in touch with
people that are doing that and then
bring you into our uh
element chat or fetaverse chat and we'll
go from there yeah
and the open source project too is
external it's not gonna it's not gonna
be owned i mean i i don't want to be
owned by anybody
right we might do a foundation that
collects donations that can help fund
the project
which the foundation would be owned
probably by timcaster or something but
the product the things that are made
would be free for public use
we probably just keep making tools that
are free you know i'd imagine why would
we stop there
if we could do it all right danine says
tim the youtube channel nando vs
v movies has a series called one small
change you should check out the episode
he did for wanda's last episode
in my honest opinion it would have been
way better to convey the message they
were trying to make
you know what i want to do i want to do
like short sketches of
changing movies and it's like just
ending movies very easily by getting rid
of the deus ex machina
or the idiot plots god game of thrones
did that the deus ex machina and game of
thrones was just so awful
yeah like we flew from the south to
north in a few hours
here we are i may destroy that series
i love how they're like trapped
surrounded by the white walkers in the
ice
behind the wall and then you know
khaleesi flies in the dragon
in a matter of what an hour like you
just knew that the the writers were
trying to reverse engineer a way to give
the white walkers a dragon like that was
the problem they were trying to solve
and they're like well we can have all
the main characters do something
obviously and horribly stupid like walk
i'll go all the way north to get a live
white walker for some reason
to prove that the white walkers are
still here i could rip on that show for
hours
yeah seriously isn't it amazing how it
was like the best show ever until the
last two seasons
the first season was so good and sean
bean
hands down probably the reason why that
was i mean it was an amazing show
because
they just they they kill i mean i don't
want to actually i shouldn't well
spoiler alert the show's been over for
five years yeah right they killed the
main character they killed the
protagonist
by the end of season one that's amazing
and i get it it is
it's amazing that was bold all right
let's see we'll do a couple more here
sora 989 says tim you don't know what
you're doing with your chicks
roosters offer more than just protection
and there's ways to keep their food and
water raised
yes this is this is true and the problem
with roosters is that we record so we
can't have one cannot have noise
yeah so we had to figure it out we were
thinking of consulting with a chicken
whisperer for
a one-off to come john goodwin says is
it possible to consider anti-gun laws as
racist due to an impact on black men
carrying unsafe neighborhoods
yes also chickens keep ticks and fleas
down
and if one chicken gets hurt and bleeds
the other chickens may try to eat the
wounded one
yes it's horrifying dinosaurs
christopher says tim you're wrong i'm a
felon been to prison trust me you don't
want people getting guns back when
they're released
some people make no effort to change and
are planning next crimes before they
before the release
no i'm not wrong i understand that
fully but the constitution says shall
not be infringed
and so long as we're not incarcerating
someone anymore i don't like the idea of
a permanent lingering effect that strips
you of yours
like five zip in the well are you paying
these people i don't know
they're paying the comment no no you
have to understand right these are all
of will's burners
that's what i've been doing on my phone
this whole time arguments are great
and a lot of the super chats want to
have their opinion heard when there's an
opinion on the show and they disagree
with
and then we read their opinion because
it's not typically not agreeing with me
and that's the point interesting
do you really think that non the uh that
violent felons
should get a gun the day they get out of
prison i didn't say that oh what do you
think exactly
if they've paid their debt to society
perhaps we say
it's five years in prison plus five
years
probationary period which was not
necessarily probation but like a
probationary period where you don't get
to vote don't get your guns back
i'm talking about when all is said and
done and what we deem to be the end of
their punishment they get their rights
back
some in some way that has to happen i
think we need to have
uh prison reform i think the bigger
problems aren't so much
whether or not a felon should have a gun
it's more so what's resulting in crime
poverty felonies anyway i don't think
people are inherently
evil i think we have problems that need
to be solved that could root out a lot
of the issues
the problem is you have a political
class hell bent on manipulating people
into making these problems worse
so they can sustain their power oh yeah
and it's it's true for the left and the
right unfortunately more so i would say
on the left to be completely honest
hence
why we find ourselves in this position
with the establishment left lying and
manipulating and cheating
and sometimes conservative saying dumb
things but
it's a it's the rule of the left and the
exception on the right
all right joseph walcott says motion
sensor sprinklers for night defense
outside your coupe works like a charm
yeah we were thinking about that all
right my friends if you haven't already
you must you must smash that like button
because it really does help
and thanks for hanging out go to
timguest.com become a member because the
members area will show you a
huge list of all of these guests and all
these bonus segments i assure you
if you're not a member and you sign up
today there is too much content for you
to be able to watch it's just too much
because i think we've been doing this
now for like three months and there's
going to be probably days worth of
content
you will be you will be com permanently
and it's not it's not all new stuff like
we had
with jim hansen and he talked about his
war stories in the philippines were
eating rotten eggs
and we try to do a lot of that for the
bonus stuff that's always evergreen and
it's always always entertaining so fun
check out yeah yeah it was fun check out
timcast.com become a member but don't
forget to like share subscribe this show
we broke a million subs with your with
with all your guys's help so we're
really really grateful for all of that
we're live monday friday at 8 pm you can
follow me on all social media platforms
at tim cast
and you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews
will you do stuff yeah i know uh
so you can follow me on twitter at will
chamberlain but i also do human events
and that's a bigger thing so we are
available at human events.com and
publish news and opinion regularly we
also you can go to youtube.com
humane events which will give you access
to my live streams that i'm not as
regular as tim
but i'm you know getting a little more
consistent with them and also
facebook.com
human events media will also get you
access to those as well
uh read the daily caller i write a ton
of stuff
every day and you can follow me on
twitter i'm jordy lancaster or
instagram i'm jordan in lancaster
yeah i'm at ian crossland ian
crossland.net and one of the things i
like about teamcast.com i was just
thinking about today is
as the days go on it the subscription
becomes more valuable because the con
that keeps
the library keeps getting bigger so it's
like you get more
great points well once once we start
prop once we start the new
uh the new shows
yeah so i'll put it this way right so
whenever everybody's becoming a member
we're using that money to make the site
better and and
there's there's roads uh there's bumps
in the road
but the money we're making is we're
hiring more people
i am not going to be let me say put it
this way
i see a lot of these people they get
they get a bunch of subscribers what do
they do
they buy a you know ferrari ferraris
infinity pools they take selfies
you know private jets private jets oh
man they fly 20 000
flights first class they're all rich and
i'm like that's money you could use to
hire someone for like
you know to write stuff to make content
to produce videos
but would you be down to get an infinity
pool no come on
darn it i would like an infinity pool
but i'm not going to spend money on a
pool when i can spend money on someone
who's going to do
awesome stuff i would like an infinity
tool too i'll put it this way if i had
my choice between an infinity pool
and giving someone a job where they're
funded to create awesome content and
culture i choose kind of the culture yes
invest in the people i am i am more
interested in
creating awesome things that inspire
people than i am and being able to sit
in the pool
i just i get inspiration from sitting in
a pool that's fair
i mean we have a sauna it's not like
but i'll tell you this everything we do
is is with the intention of making
something of it
so when we built the skate park in the
garage it's because it's actually a
venue where we're gonna have events and
we're gonna do live streams
so the goal is in the future for
everyone listening friday nights are
going to become
big events where we do the show and then
we segue into the outdoor cameras where
we have a comedian or a musician
or i don't know maybe a skateboarder and
we just have a hangout with like beers
and barbecue
and we make it a free like probably hour
long maybe two hour long thing where
it's like a friday night hangout
now we're gonna do one night where
members actually have the ability to buy
tickets to actu
to come out it'll be limited probably
like 20 tickets because
we want an audience watching and you
know the camera's rolling
but it's not a big venue so we can't
literally have everybody but that's the
plan man
it's going to be it's going to be me you
do cool stuff like um we could stream
live tim cast irl like one camera angle
of the venue and then if you go to
timcast.com as a subscriber you get like
five more angles no no no we're gonna
we're gonna have it produce a multicam
and everything nice
yeah yeah because we're gonna we're
gonna have panning cameras mounted
and then all we have to do is just you
know have one person on controls
and so uh i wanna do i wanna do events
so like friday night there are probably
a lot of people who are like uh
you know i don't care to watch a talk
show but i'd love to see a stand-up
comedy thing from somebody with multiple
comedians
the other thing we're going to do too is
periodic very very special events that
would be effectively pay-per-view where
it's like
i would like to get prominent comedians
to do a show as if it were any other
venue
but that means they'll want standard
venue procedures where it's like people
pay tickets they get a percentage of the
ticket sales
so we would just do a digital venue
where it's like okay we're going to do a
special event
you know sunday night with like these
four comedians it's a five dollar ticket
for entry
and then it's online and then they get a
portion of the of the sales as
you know as they do so yeah man a lot a
lot of big plans in that direction love
you tim oh it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun uh did
you shout out i did not so i will say my
two cents on this is that i think the
issue that the guys are talking about is
entirely cultural
um which is not something that you can
fix from the top down you fix it from
the bottom up and that's one of the
things we're doing at timcast.com
but you can follow me at sourpatchlids
on twitter and mines
everybody it's friday night thanks for
hanging out we are gonna be back monday
at 8 p.m
and uh we're gonna be doing some fun
stuff this weekend so we did film a vlog
last sunday and we had this this pro bmx
guy mike feedy he did
he grind on the grind bar and uh we're
building out the new vlog
section you can see it at timecast.com
it's just nothing there yet
but uh we have a video that's going to
go up and we're going to be filming more
this weekend and we're gonna start
filming more
i'll i'll give you this advice i say to
everybody to explain why we're doing it
this way
you just start doing it that means we're
not gonna have it daily even though it
says daily but eventually the goal is to
get it every single day
filming something doing something having
fun making it exciting so i hope you're
around for that
thank you all so much for hanging out
and we'll see you all on monday bye guys
you